salut la france salue kevin bonjour à
tous donc maxime écoute chalon il te
féliciter tout ça pour le championnat de
france officiellement et tout mais on va
attendre deux trois petites minutes
histoire que les gens arrivent parce que
sinon ça va être en mode on parle tout
seul et personne n'aurait rien dans ton
cul ok on attend on attend on s'installe
je sais pas ce que veut dire une
connerie ou quoi mais tu peux que
féliciter quand même si de ce script de
félicitations en fait c'est ça mais tu
arrêtes avait vu le commentaire de
qualité quand même sur sur ta victoire
j'ai vu j'ai vu la fin oui en fait j'ai
vu une vidéo de moi qui met un vent à
laurent blanc que blanc
laurent laurent menée en france a vu sa
très bonne vidéo et dit ce prix que nous
en noir et blanc cas avec hello darkness
my old friend quoi été voir en pls qu
mais pour le coup tu vois je me rappelle
pas du tout de mettre prix en gros comme
ça sinon j'aurais j'aurais mal agi tut
les bien manger quand même oui mais
j'étais quand j'ai vu la vidéo j'ai été
très surpris que ça ça lui arrive j'ai
bien aimé le petit geste de la main
genre rech
après il s'est vraiment chaud dans la
salle pour le coup donc c'est vraiment
mettez des têtes aussi dans un état un
peu second entre guillemets jacques
hermant comment mais ouais enfin je sais
pas si tu sais à l'occasion un jour tu
revois les les commentaires je parle un
petit peu du de latitude en terme en
termes de ton de ton body language en
fait pendant le pendant le match mais
clairement tu avais l'air hyper
déterminer en fait au début première
partie j'étais très stressée et je pense
que ça c'est ça c'est vu georges
arrivais pas je vais j'y vais pas me
présenter jeudi à trop d'enjeu et une
fois que j'ai perdu je me suis dit j'ai
plus rien à perdre et en fait c'est mon
père m'a fait exactement la même benoît
m'a dit une fois que j'ai perdu j'ai
commencé à mettre les coudes sur la
table
ouais on était bien après et oui et ça a
changé de body language laurent est
devenu un peu plus tu vois stressé
- l'averse du coup on peut dire que ton
père écouter les commentaires et il est
aidé à tous tes côtés je servais très
intéressant ce qu'ils sont en train de
dire mais là je sais très bien ce qu'il
fait ce monsieur blaise primes là ils
devaient être pris parce qu'on est fait
en mode après pas qu'ils regardent leur
est pas fou qui garde une bonne image
non mais c'est vrai vraiment avait l'air
vraiment déterminé quoi c'était serré
que la première partie on s'est pas fait
le bon c'est pas fait le rapprochement
n'a commencé à se le faire c'est vrai la
deuxième quant à commence à attaquer à
fermer tout avait l'air tellement non
mais j'étais vraiment stressé de avons
pas un truc qui m'arrive jamais
normalement quand je joue je suis hyper
stressée nature et la whey quand je suis
arrivé au départage était vraiment ce pc
en plus laurent c'est quelqu'un que je
trouve vraiment fort je me disais avant
la partie comment est ce que je vais
passer l'ouverture parce qu'elle est
très bien préparée tu vois oui
d'ailleurs en l'ong tamar est avec un
peu de mal non non il a juste mais il a
récité ce qu'ils connaissaient après la
parfaitement jouer donc je pouvais pas
il a fait pareil à la première partie du
recul du coût
j'ai joué ps3 pour sortir de la théorie
il m'a sorti un système qui connaissait
il m'a juste heures ouais ça ressemble
un peu ta partie d'ailleurs à au parti
de 45 contre contre maxime celle en
langue carlson pour une maxime qui joue
la première contre eux mvl à la
particratie étudiants est exactement le
même système
ouais ouais dans l'esprit même la partie
à leur semblait genre de la nation et 20
c'était vraiment avait l'impression d'un
copier-coller cd jeune padawan quoi
allez-vous les fatickois les mini cars
le cndd contre mini mv et genre le même
scénario s'était non mais j'ai fait un
très mauvais choix d'ouverture contre
cofres
ouais mais bon après après tu as réussi
à arracher le titre contre fraysse quoi
du coup à l'arraché et tu avais peur des
départagea 3 ou pas ouais alors oui
clairement je voulais pas un départage
avec jules fraysse et moi parce que j'ai
eue lors était très déterminé les très
forts dans les cadences rapides your way
ça doit être le
et fraises pour moi c'était le meilleur
du tournoi caraman ce qui est mon favori
avant le rend la compet et donc du coup
c'est pour ça que j'ai joué la gagne
contre côtes sally à tout prix wii party
est assez facile d'ailleurs au final en
tout cas dans le temps au niveau du
temps en termes de courir la position
s'est passé ça j'imagine
j'imagine mais ça nous a paru une
victoire facile pour toi quoi le bleu
pour le coup j'étais plutôt content
10h10
donc je vais profiter avec le match est
commencé pour te présenter c'est comme
monter a fait une première fois mais
comme je disais tu vois tous les gens
sont en train d'arriver un tu peux voir
le chat ici donc un maxime lagarde
champion de france 2010 neuf donc bravo
à toi on chantait emerson est un des
grands espoirs entre guillemets des
échecs français
alors je vais mettre un petit bémol même
si tu es là peut-être pas pour le titre
de champion de monde une accordera
j'imagine mais mettez un des joueurs
français qui peut arriver dans les deux
mille sept cents lots donc clairement tu
étais un thé un poids lourd des échecs
français
j'espérais et tu es sélectionné pour la
première fois en équipe de france c'est
ça pour les championnats d'europe à
batoumi lyon et donc tu représentera
notre pays et tu fais partie des
générations de cas l'année du coup je
suis 94 je suis là même quasiment la
même génération que jules qui est 95
ouais donc t2c génération des années 90
qu'on va dire entre les salles et
peut-être marizy quoi tu es salam
pétrole cesse à dompter de ce côté-là et
et donc ils ont que c'est la première
fois que tu fais des commentaires c'est
la première fois que je fais les
commentaires en live sur internet oui
j'avais déjà commenté une pro che slick
d'accord ouais mais on va dire que
c'était semi enfin c'était c'était
complètement officieux quand on était
convaincu la mairie
ouais mais en live comme ça sur internet
oui ok ok et du coup qu'est ce que tu
veux tu rajouter quelque chose pour les
gens qui ne connaissent pas je crois que
tu as tout dit garriott plus à rajouter
je suis très contente de commenter les
toits merci d'avoir fait c'est nous qui
avons l'honneur de t'avoir tu vois moi
je mets mais je mets un petit masque tu
vois j'ai un genre de nez rouge papote
et quand même champion de france et ou
face et c'est beau et oui on disait un
truc d'ailleurs marrant justement ça me
permet de faire le la transition c'est
que l'on disait que c'était champion de
france d'échecs tout en étant le numéro
2 des maximes serre que la cession ne
comprend plus quoi pour le coup dans les
échecs pour les 1/4 d'un seul on
m'appelle le rom maxime le mauvais
maximum en mariage on a raconté une
anecdote que tu jouais contre nakamura à
gibraltar et qui s'était qu'il avait vu
maxime lag dans le temps les
appariements et qui s'était préparée
contre mvl oui oui mais on m'a raconté
cette anecdote or je sais pas quel point
c'est vrai mais on m'a raconté ça hier
ou avant-hier
je suis pas sûr parce que vous
connaissez l'adage parce qu'on sait
nager avec macarons jouer sur sa chaise
dot com
ben apparemment il aurait il au il
aurait vu des appariements qu'avec les
trois premières lettres parce qu'il a
plus en plus sales bêtes je vais pas
dans le tournoi tu vois là donc c'est
une fausse rumeur où c'était c'est
peut-être une blague de naka du cookie
qui raconte samoa du couteau windows du
coup un faux truc donc tu vas d'entrée
je démarre fort quoi je raconte de la
bière on écrit dans le chat le fake quoi
car je passe tu connais la chaîne de
déféquer à tort peut-être sur you tube
non non c'est un mec qui prend des faits
qui est il et qui les démonte de manière
un peu un peu humble ristic
tu es dehors ça c'est sûr voilà j'étais
dedans et donc attendons klein était
lives et maxi maxime et ouais donc ce
match en fait qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que tu en penses
une belle contre voyez je pense que ça
va être serré mais qu'au final une belle
va gagner je pense à tuchan tuchan
maxime quand même fort mais tu penses
serré quand même tu pense que oui j'en
fais ça sérieux tu pense qu'il va y vas
y vas y vas y vas contre et elles sont
toujours ça va accélérer plus voyez pas
te dire mais qu'est ce donc là en 5 + 5
ans c'est le moment où il faut faire un
peu la journée en train de plus de
maxime peur d'exposer oui ouais tu l'as
tu la sens bien quoi donc là cette
partie je sais pas si tu as regardé
pendant que je regardais beaucoup
c'était un orgue this way et du coup là
tu vas m'éclairer parce que je comprends
pas pourquoi les noirs perdrait pas un
pion pas d'ailleurs c'est une très bonne
question de y avoir du contre g8 b4 tour
ces deux peut-être en a on a un petit
hors 10,1 pour cdg un ordi la cgt dans
ta mère tu veux que j'enlève ouais c'est
mieux de l'enlever vent a legend of mr
mais juste si jamais on leur met pas ce
qu'on trouve pas un truc on le dira
l'accord faut que je ferme la fenêtre
parce que c'était ma question de début
voix il ya eu un tram qui est passé mais
bon voilà c'est plus très gênant je sais
pas ça dépend à quelle est la haye a
enfreint toutes les cinq minutes
bref d'être fermé alors ça passe à fond
devant chez toi qui fais un crime donc
voilà on va comprendre du coup pourquoi
est ce que le pion des six c'était pas
si fort donc tu pense qu'il ya du contre
jeu ouais tu tour ces deux du mais là
c'est pas le web et c'est facile car moi
j'aime bien les lorrains jalbert soit un
joueur qui est un peu seul accusé a
battu sais comment joue au hockey de
l'activité en fait tu as vraiment un
style
similaire à celui de maxime en moins
forte on a peur problème si la wii c'est
à peu près à peu près le même joueur
quoi tintin mini maxime quand je suis un
mauvais maxime j'ai vu ses choix sur
maxime pas ce que tu veux mais c'est
marrant parce qu'en fait moi aussi j'ai
le même style que maxime donc que toi
dans le dans le fond mais encore en
moins fort quoi ça profite à des degrés
de nullité quoi les mecs sont plus en
plus nul avec le même style on va se
retrouver avec des douches sans quoi au
final c c est fou et pour le coup je
pense qu'il ya personne au pied de
maxime dans ce style
non non il ya personne choisie maxime
c'est numéro un mais en dessous quand
même y en a beaucoup
en dessous il aurait beaucoup ça c'est à
la maintenance à leur tour ces huit fois
chic et 17 donc attendre vraiment ça
s'arrête jouer les fois ci ce qui a aidé
cette fois peut-être poussé 5 faucons v4
pan ou c5 et surtout en d2 fou prend la
fuite
ouais par exemple les poussettes 5 et 17
fou combien 4 ya tour en échec pour f2
qui des projets dans l'otan l'audience
ça y est je fais n'importe quoi et
fourchette
ok tu vois c'est toujours un peu un peu
triki ce genre de collision mais tu
penses qu'un mec comme moi oui ça il
avait vu à l'avance ou
et oui c'est un joueur qui joue à
l'instant ok place ces pièces et puis
après il boit il est très fort en
tactique en attaque mais joe cole un
sens mais est-ce que du coup c'est pas
un peu le même style que toi avec maxime
ans on sait bien de quoi rentrer plus
proches de maxime peine mois mais j'irai
qui les rend encore plus calcul que
maxim maksimov c'est vraiment c'est un
calcul intuitif alan initiative qui va
beaucoup d'initiatives et oui c'est
vraiment du cal culture je sais pas si
tu comprends je comprends je comprends
ce que tu ce que tu veux dire pour
essayer de je pense que tout le monde a
compris tu veux dire que que maxime sait
vraiment si c'est plus un peu un peu
comme shirov moi je veux dire tu sens
les pieds ouais c'est ça c'est un peu un
peu comme sûrs et oui c'est alors que
plusieurs ordinateurs tu vois un peu du
carroi nac
oui tout ça quoi ouais mais je sais pas
si tu as vu la super party drouilly
qu'il avait qui avait bâti son
adversaire en au milieu des chez qui
elle avait été élue meilleure partie
d'année où j'ai plus bas ouais je
l'avais je l'avais jamais fait sur sur
la place du tube c'était impressionnant
en termes de calcul de profondeur de
calcul des heures à y avait eu même un
petit coup silencieux au milieu qui
n'était pas sûrement durable la mémoire
et havrais donc ça ces calculs calcul et
que ce soit toi ô maxime tu parfois tu
calcules pas tout quoi tu sens le
positionnement des pièces et la suite
réseau l'instant siens ouais mais bon tu
calcules quand même bien quand il faut
calculer qu'en fait quand je sens que ça
gagne je me force à calculer mais de
manière générale c'est pour ça que je
fais bout quand je fais des parties il
est parti que je perds c'est que je
trouve rien de concret et que je tombe
des trucs et que je fais tu vois je me
fais retourner parce que je n'ai pas
joué pression et tu travailles ton
calcul ou pas du coup non
c'est le je pense c'est le seul truc que
je travaille pas dans les échecs et
tu penses que ça peut être quelque chose
qui te manque du coup non non non parce
que c'est ce que tu as et ce que je te
dis quand je sais que la police ont
gagné que que le calcul est forcé je
vais réussir à calculer getty arrive
quand-même hockey voyagez pas cher ezio
non mais tu calcules bien aimé mais
c'était juste voir pour élargir et pour
voir un peu là que tu ce que tu penses
être toi même quoi c'est intéressant de
la mâchoire
je sais où sont mes défauts clairement
c'est que je suis pas du tout technique
donc là que c'est en finale tout ça tu
as du mal tu vois je suis pas je suis
pas patient comme john quand il faut
jouer des petits coups ou limiter le
contre jeu et tout ça c'est pas c'est
pas mon style t'es pas un bout de vie
nique
alors je suis prête pénique du tout et
je suis pas théoriquement plus le détour
donc tu sortais pas théorique du tout
parce que tu te prépares pas assez ou
pas ce que je déteste me préparer en rép
ouais ouais en fait c'est surtout sa
liste
je sais que je déteste me préparer
j'aime pas perdre du temps sur mon ordi
à apprendre des variantes et comment tu
souhaite remédier du cou à ces deux
assez de faiblesse eh bien je souhaite
prendre un second gros qui va m'envoyer
des bases et que je vais pas chercher
pas où aller du goût du vin genre de
vlad quoi chez ça tu cherches le ton de
la ddt
ça c'est très très cher
j'avais beau problème non mais vraiment
c'est pas évident d'avoir son vlad
non je sais bien mais mais bon ça peut
se faire baisser problème aussi c'est
qu'en france on a pas on n'a pas
beaucoup de de sponsoring et de
responsables et joueurs j'ai réussi à me
faire sponsoriser un peu par mon club
que je remercie d'ailleurs je vais faire
de placement grève a dit tu peux
franchement tu peux y aller parce que ça
fait plaisir de deux côtés des gens
quittent est donc ni salikhiine donc
c'est mon club français est le sponsor
s'est échappée une grosse boîte
allemande voilà quand les bêtes d'un peu
ils financent quelques cours et quelques
tournois donc sa tête vraiment avoir des
gens qui te sawiris ahmed clairement pas
ce que c'est c'est mine de rien même si
tu es champion de france tu gagnes pas
une fortune dans une année en tant que
joueur d'échecs clairement clairement si
tu peux avoir une aide financière c'est
toujours à ben c'est pas le
c'est de rêve quoi non c'est pas le
métier de rêve financièrement c'est vrai
que c'est un peu un peu juste et réussir
à sauver sa peau il va tomber oui ouais
parce qu'il a une connexion en carton
papier mâché peut-être ah oui nos braves
gens nuls après je pense pas un maxi
1000 c'est quand même un mec très fair
play et lillers - est moins bien comme
ça et tu vois il essaye de de hockey le
trio le triton me tombe non oui mes
joueurs si si un père pète ou quoi tu
vois je pense pas qu'il aille jouer un
coup qui perd en un pur pour essayer
avec toi c'est pas en accord non non si
fait tomber parce que le tabac de
connexion est juste la position des
choses il va le faire mais s'il est
foutu et que juste tu vois comme là
c'était que ça répète je le vois pas je
vois pas maxime
non je suis d'accord c'est donc encore
une âge d'or une femme d'âge d'or toute
la soirée à toi tu joues quoi du coup
contre 4 ça dépend je joue de la sienne
très très généralement sicilienne un peu
de françaises et français ça correspond
moyenne dragon style nom de vue de vue
de loin ça dépend la quête pour ça que
j'ai choisi un revêtement tous nos
adversaires que je veux ton adversaire
tu peux tu peux placer une française et
je joue pas mal de enquéri 6,6 comme tu
as pu voir en pro che slim ouais c'est
pas mal ça comme ouverture c'est pas mal
compté genre un peu plus cher c'est de
gagner
mais magnus l'avait utilisé d'ailleurs
ouais ouais beaucoup de foi et un bon
tas de bons résultats avec ça j'étais
super résultat je crois que j'ai pas
perdre une partie accueilli 6,6 après je
choisis mes adversaires aussi c'est
pareil c'est pas des adversaires très
avec un bon classement tu fais quand
même très attention si tu parles de gens
à moins de 2004 puis pourrait devenir
vexant fait très attention c'est des
mecs complètement nul et sourd sur 524
jah verity abattre un ennemi indien à
24,50 encaissé 6 alors j'en ai perdu
notre champion d'europe sur les peurs
d'une je me suis fait j'ai finalement
j'en étais très attention avec inquiète
pas on a l'habitude surtout les mecs du
chat ils se sont défoncés sans arrêt
c'est dès que je suis un peu salée puis
de mauvaise humeur
c'est ouais ouais ouais c'est toute
façon les 1800 du chat
c'est quoi la moyenne du chap à le logic
de large c'est celui qu'a fait la vidéo
n'ont ni cerveau très mobiles
tu valides je valide tu vas y et ludique
de large parce qu'en fait si tu dis je
valide unique de largeur un truc comme
ça ça va être pris dans d'autres
montages après certifie pas faire un
clip il va garder la vidéo est un moment
donné tu verras si mme lagarde qui
apparaît qu'il dit je validerais
s'inspire de l'art je serai forcément tu
vas y ma trogne a pas longtemps quand
j'ai fait 2800 sur czech comme moi je
fais gaffe à vos images il m'a fait quoi
il me mets à la fin de la vidéo il me
fait un montage à la fin de la vidéo il
met un mec qui dit tu vas quand même que
nous gagner un peu quelque chose un
petit peu quelque chose c'est un mec
marrant
donc si tu regardes les montages sur ma
chaîne qui sont faits un peu fun c'est
toujours l'unique joker c'est un bon
franchement sain bon c'est un bon du
coup cette position ce qui a valu en d5
moi j'ai envie de te dire tu vois
j'essaie de m'accrocher un truc que je
vois crois que c'est une position
classique voilà au foot qu'on échange
jusque là maintenant il doit prendre
avec le pion à 16 heures en l'air s'il
prend like l'adhan tu penses d'un
français de très fort pour penser
devrait puis attend que penser d'hommes
b3 peut-être pour ces six pour ces six
dames 17,28 a déjà faim qui tenaillait
quoi aller rapidement car il est paré de
former ensemble un sérieux serious un
bon service un bon je le connais je
connais un petit peu il était chez moi
c'est un bon c'est un très bon même ça
fait il a fait aussi un remix sur robert
s je t'enverrai après si tu veux
s'appelle robert électrodes pour chelsea
wayne mais en fait c'est l'art est pour
robert s c'est un genre d'expressions
qu'on a et et ludwig a réussi à lui
faire dire sur son chat est donc et donc
robert savais pas trop ce que ça voulait
dire mais du coup du coup du coup ça a
été clippé pense assez marrant mais non
mais il est puni les mêmes yeux la
maxime en bataille commence a tenu à
peut-être les actifs de parfums mieux
peut-être points 5 et tour à 2,7 m
quelques épreuves 1,3 mb this way je
préfère les normes ou g5 d'un me payer 3
nantes arrive de partout non bah tu peux
oui oui et non car ça peut être
objectivement égal mais c'est plus
agréable
il va falloir le faire quand même avec
les blancs et oui il ya toujours la même
tête voit donc du coup tu n'en sais rien
tu veux te donne sur les jours tu
pourrais dire sur le visage ce que je
peux voir quelque chose mais pokerface
ouais on l'a vu sourire une fois on a
gagné un armageddon partie armageddon il
a gagné il veut un petit sourire
armageddon la série de digues mais
rennes est plus agréable
oh ouais fusée expressif en tout cas
plus expressive ouais non il est une
petite tête sympa et ding là il est très
sympa ça va tu le connais un petit peu
en dehors
non je connais pas personnellement mais
lorsque je vois dans le zinc à vue et
tout ça je trouve que très sympa non il
a franchement je suis d'accord il a
l'air il a l'air très serein très cool
magnus et l'air d'avoir son caractère
quand même sympa mais avec son caractère
venus faut le prendre quand il a gagné
une partie n'a pas l'air de maxime très
sympa qu'on en parle les gens le savent
mais max est perturbé très très sympa
nation à haut niveau il ya bien il ya
des mecs dans les échecs sans donner de
nom il ya des mecs vraiment tu dis lui
toi y en a certains qui m'énerve mais
bon c'est pareil je connais pas
personnellement
ouais t'as pas de je pourrais je peux je
peux te donner des noms cette fâcheuse
et je veux lâcher des blattes tu peux y
aller mais après ça peut jouer des tours
enfin bon non mais par exemple je sais
que tu n'as qu'à quand ils paieraient
pas très agréable
ouais c'est sûr mais ouais mais non mes
joueurs n'a qu'a tu peux y aller quoi tu
vois c'est pas nous c'est bon on n'a
qu'à ça va maka il a l'habitude
t'es pas le premier depuis répété
kirsten et pire quand il perd non mais
c'est vrai car le cnc quand il perd
encore que là c'est un gars c'est le web
carson d'un terrible
bon après c'est ce qui fait sa marque de
fabrique
c'est pour ça que c'est un champion et
toi du coup quand tu perds tu es comment
ça dépend de la manière dont j'ai peur
par exemple quand j'ai perdu contre
fraysse ça m'a pas trop impacter basque
et j'ai fait un mauvais choix et après
le juste parfaitement jouer donc c'est à
partir de ce moment le mec je peux
parfaitement il est meilleur
ça sert à rien de commencer quand tu
perds une partie que tu penses tu pas si
je suis complètement gagnant là où que
le mec que je trouve vraiment nul
je suis pas très agréable mais donc
c'est un mec moins bien classés où ça
peut être des mecs c'est pas forcément
voir ça peut être de tout aussi issus
ok c'est souvent quand je suis moi même
quand ils sont moins bien classés oui ça
avait l'air plus plus si je perds je
suis complètement gagnant contre 1,27
comme je l'étais narbé pareil ok donc
c'est pas une question de vélo c'est
plus une question de la non du fait que
nos mis de la partie que ça cesse a est
la plus grosse perte d'ailleurs
contraint c'est que ceux qui devant le
plus fort que t'es battu en longues que
j'ai battu il ya neuf
du coup c'est pour ça que j'avais
préparé pour ça que tu fasses un petit
peu avec lui vous dis oui
il n'a pas l'air très très fort je vais
bosser avec lui à fond c'était une
grosse partie par ces présentations mais
il était sûrement aux alentours de 27 30
et à 17 20 et en rapide blitz dans les
tons à de rapides beats woippy ce
camaïeu rapide bits ce tu arrêtes a
quand même un niveau assez assez
conséquent qua non mais ho ching 27 je
crois pas beaucoup de 26,85 oui après tu
as peut-être pas forcément l'occasion
d'en jouer beaucoup n'ont pas si j'ai
pas de chiffres rogers va sûrement aller
bonfi roja tu as battu rapide à je peux
la france non il est bon mais il tilt un
peu et j'ai pas trouvé monstrueux ce
tournoi je vais peut-être passer points
non mais je n'ai vraiment pas trouvé mon
seul
rapide en but d'ailleurs en plus il a
fait un très mauvais tournant et s'est
même pas qualifié et en rapide j'étais
gagnants dans les trois parties du jeu
compte j'en ai gagné qu'une
malheureusement et sa tasse le fit pour
pour passer dans gagner nous non c'était
en quarts de finale que je joue et j'ai
gagné la première je perds le deuxième
mais après l'armageddon je perds
complètement gagnant du coup xk et tu
t'en penses quoi du coup de fil rouge a
vu qu'on parle de ça qui pensent qu'il
peut pas rentrer chez rhodia il est
impressionnant en classique partie
classique tu trouves plus impressionnant
classique du coup ah ouais je trouve
plus impressionnantes la cible après
après sa très cintrée forgeur saison que
j'ai ou 15 ch et ses bas je crois qu'il
a 16 mai il va y sera reconstruit tu
pense qu'il peut il peut devenir
champion du monde
dormons et ouais à propos de fuir ou
tchadors ton avis toi qui es dunes d'une
génération plus en plus jeunes que les
que les invités qu'on a géré a
généralement tu penses que est-ce que
c'est mauvais de faire autant de bullet
et de et d'hyper bullet et tout ça sur
internet où tu penses que c'est ce je
pense pas que ce soit mon vin
franchement je vois pas pourquoi ça
serait mon verbe il a gagné il a gagné
la guerre
non je vois pas pourquoi ce serait mon
gars se développe les réflexes as tu
vois c'est marrant parce que quand on en
parle avec vlad qui est d'une autre
génération
ouais en fait ouais il dit que ça te ça
te fait perdre l'habitude de chercher le
meilleur coût et la vérité mais d'un
autre côté il disait pour pour un peu
abaissé son son propos que en fait et
génère une nouvelle génération vous
jouez de beaucoup plus pratique que à
son époque noël etc c'est assez efficace
en réalité ouais il ya ya ya de ça aussi
il ya aussi le fait de plus du jeu de
bullet plus tu vas de position
différentes moi c'est un peu ce qu'est
ce qui m'arrive c'est que je vois
beaucoup de pression différente
et mine de rien tu apprends d'état
reprend des nouvelles choses quand des
mecs qui sont pas mauvais par exemple
michael ambühl est je vois à quel point
ils calculent vis de certaines positions
il comprend bien la position et je pense
qu'inconsciemment tu as tu vas tu
apprends les positions et du couture et
analyses parfois les bulles est que tu
joues non pas chez vous il m'arrivait de
regarder des ouvertures closing alco
parce que ces calculs de la
particularité de jouer tous auraient
portant un pull est bonne santé
financière sortir les prépas les trucs
les nouveautés etc
et du coup c'est intéressant de regarder
derrière les savoirs sur ok donc et tu
joues en hyper bullet ou en ultra light
révèle être du fait qu'une lettre
oui et puis je joue quasiment que je
fais que tu puisses tu joues sur
tu cherches tu as moins 15 du coût fixe
ouais on peut te voir parfois et tu le
tut tut organise des matchs qu'on
démarre fort parfois genre quand tu
joues contre firoud déjà ou contrevenant
mais en fait je troll beaucoup mes
adversaires quand je joue sanchez
d'autres clubs je joue à trois baies 3
c3 tétreault at il fait du genre de
méthode ruiz ne les arrête toi quoi
ouais et en fait ça énerve mes
adversaires et donc du coup je sais pas
ils ne veulent plus jouer quoi ouais
c'est ça il veut le juger parce qu'ils
pensent que que je me fous un peu d'eux
alors que ce simplement ma façon de
détendre quand je jouais en ligne oui tu
t'amuses quoi ouais je m'avise j'arrive
à les battre et ils pleurent derrière
hawks mais ils font toujours ça quand tu
commences à les battre en jouant des
choses un peu bizarre ils sont pas
contents alors que ce n'est pas du tout
contre spécialement ces risques tu vois
j'aime bien avoir des positions à
défendre je trouve ça plus le même thème
faire du sale c'est ça meiway en pro
chelsea que tu avais réussi à taper
réussi à mettre en difficulté
je rappelle le joueur islandais qui
avait fait une grotte et trois pions de
moins tu vas avoir arnaqué c'était 5 ça
ouais mais tu vois là alors c'est pas du
tout je connaissais même pas de
l'adversaire c'est juste que je prends
plus de plaisir à faire des parties un
peu morne comme ça que qu'à jouer
sérieusement les open
donc cette année en pro de chasse ligue
on peut s'attendre à de nouvelles
approches est différent parce qu'on joue
par équipe donc je n'ai pas non plus
envie de nous faire une petite grappe
raid
enfin je te ferai une trop belle il faut
quand même
non je suis pas un stan et du coup on en
parle un peu avant entre nous en priver
entre guillemets et donc on était chauds
on était quand même chaud pour la saison
qui arrive normalement ça devrait
commencer en janvier mais comme je te
disais on connaît pas encore le format
cette saison mais ça devrait comme comme
les gens dans le tchad doivent doivent
s'intéresser à la compétition ça devrait
être plus ça aurait plus être au tour
des équipes qui ont vraiment des
supporters et qu'ils ont vraiment une
fanbase si on peut dire ça comme ça et
c'est plutôt à notre avantage 6 à 6 à
tourner dans ce délire ça pourrait être
ça pourrait être sympa et on peut avoir
l'occasion peut-être de faire de
meilleurs résultats que les saisons
précédentes on s'est un peu éliminées
toujours en huitièmes où ankara cette
année c'est en huitièmes non
cette année on s'est fait éliminer par
qui par les norvégiens alors là j'ai
fait 0 sur 4
moulle gros match n'était pas l'anglais
n'a pas accordé beaucoup
non franchement franchement je pense que
c'est moi qui bouffent le match
honnêtement non mais franchement je dois
je dois faire minimum un sur quatre en
fait enfin problème c'est que je domine
domec et et au lieu de jouer vite et
juste de garder du temps et faire nul
j'ai envie de les punir
et je prends beaucoup de temps et je me
duval à la pendule et je perds un peu
comme gary hier soir à n'importe quoi
mais ça c'est le manque de pratique
tu verras ça un jour tu pratiques de
google
ouais mais il joue pas ces cadences la
aouichette passé cadence
ouais c'est ça le problème c'est que mes
gars y pareil en fait il fait vraiment
des blitz sur internet et tout mais
quand avait plus l'habitude d'aller
première fois que j'ai rejoint en partie
longue
quand j'ai repris ses pas dans les
conseils ça pour les gens qui reprennent
mais après vingt-deux coup il me restait
dix minutes tu vois alors tu peux dire
le mec fait des beats sur internet il
joue vite
en fait en partie longue du coup j'ai
plus du tout le toit j'ai plus le drive
quoi donc
non c'est bizarre en fait c'est du jer
moins bien les cadences quant à plus de
temps tu sais plus comment l'utiliser
best buy et n'importe quoi parce que
disait le bla d'abord notre façon de
réfléchir conséquence est plus long
ouais c'est différent c'est complètement
différent
donc du coup je veux aller trop en
profondeur et puis du coup je me
rappelle plus des ventes que je calcule
enfin c'est une cata et donc cette
petite française
enfin sicilienne qui s'est transformé en
structure française la salers alors une
paire pas un pion tu vois le 5 c'est
typiquement je veux actifs ont d'abord
et puis on ouvre tout donc il veut quoi
il veut plus on prend qu'à la vie prend
way et à 14 heures mais tu vois tu vois
tu contrôles sur f2 alors attends tu
prends dans quel sens sabella je pense
que l'om va prendre et ça arrête toi
peut-être quatre direct pour pas pour
pas se faire échanger d'amendé ray
remote kirill est fou prend feu profond
tourcoing puis on prend et là je pense
qu'il faut jouer un coup de fouet mais
tu vois c'est pas si simple que ces cinq
cars yeux
et puis peut-être détroit après ouais
paris l'a fait comment maxime et la
prairie prix prix ici oui des quais bas
il ya bien calculé donc le meilleur du
fou prend du dommage car arrivée au bras
de fer dame b 3 chaque intermédiaire ok
meilleur accueil vous proche de nancy va
faire froid je suis allé il a fouillé
des cinq aussi qu'elle fout des simples
deviennent une place dans vos dessins
qu'il a oublié non je pense qu'il est
obligé parce que ça leur donne une pièce
sous les 5 ça attaque la dame sur tous
ces cas tu auras fou prend ses quatre
jeux dessins j'ai attendu pouvait par
équipes couru cinq quelque part non
ouais enfin il était moins bien dans
tous les cas mais faire un truc il y
avait la tour mais pas maintenant
il y avait foule pointe de deux
mascottes qui arrivait oui mais sûr sûr
sûr d'alzheimer dame vous prend acte
d'un match 4 d'un problème de pions
prend la relève
c'était fini donc ça va faire les demi
heures et demie neige d'or donc écoute
je te propose qu'on se concentre un peu
plus sur les parties au début nous
fallait cette petite discussion le match
et l'on a dû rater il reste combien de
temps il reste encore une heure de 5 + 5
tu en as le temps il joue trois heures
il joue 3 hervé jouer trois heures ouais
mais bon faut que tu te qualifies l'an
prochain mais c'était quoi le truc pour
se qualifier c'était le truc de budget
non c'est un truc de title tuesday ou un
tournant quoi mais mais je verrai l'an
prochain puisque parfois là quand ils
font les uns invitationnal les uns et
les tons à l'invitation pour se
qualifier
faudrait que je glisse faudra que je
glisse des non-blancs plus comme tu es
champion de france je glisserais
peut-être ton nom maxime la gare de péry
coup de french players il joue le titre
les amis il est très très fort
pourquoi pas après c'est dur de se
qualifier c'est vous c'est violent mais
bon pourquoi pas je crois que l'an
dernier c'est dominguez qui s'était
qualifié tu vois ok ah oui je prends mon
violon violon il avait battu meilleur
en finale je crois qui est pas mauvais
donc c'est la même position que dans la
partie précédente non ce sera toujours
les mêmes
je crois qu'il ya une urgence la non qui
est venu donc c'est quoi en fait les
idées dans cette position pour pour les
bars et accueille des 100 kg
les blondes rousses il jouait les dames
de casser les dames et les noirs
arrivent aussi de trouver du contre jeu
sur le roi avec rocket 5 h 4 bat donc en
gros il ya un camp qui attaque un
endroit à l'autre camp qui attaquent à
chasser ça donc ils vont prendre de
l'espace par à 5 normalement à 5 foot tu
vois fou 3 à un moment il m'a aussi de
wc3 ouais donc le bouffer le pion et
après bekkat bessin qui précède avoir un
pion passé à c'est le truc classique ces
attaques allaient là mais contre je leur
accorde donc c'est le même esprit par
les mêmes positions et mali même esprit
qu'une est indienne pour ces lots bin
ouais ouais c'est ça il menacé le fou
des deux qui détient plomb donc le tour
bus tu vas y tu écrives tu vas maxime
lagarde meilleur potentiel plus meilleur
potentiel puisque 40 scène ouverte avec
ce truc de vrais chefs fig
j'ai commencéà j'ai commencé à 6 ans des
échecs comment tu as tu as commencé par
hasard
non mon frère josé chèque en raid 1 mais
ils m'ont connu il est un peu moins
connus il joue bien ou pas du coup là il
doit être dit d'arrêter fin un jour plus
beaucoup il doit être 18 cents quelque
chose comme ça c'est bien sans être bien
quoi mais il avait un style eu de cours
lui il envoyait toutes ces pièces ça
passait ou ça passait pas mais on
sacrifier tout juste c'est marrant
parfois dans des familles pourquoi tu as
un frère qui est très doué dans quelque
chose l'autre - enfin tu rates moi c'est
un truc qui m'a toujours là je pense que
j'étais plus intéressé que lui ça aide
il a fait beaucoup de beaucoup de choses
et il joue encore de temps en temps pas
très peur et il est pâtissier en fait
presque on
et crier plus fort en pâtisserie ah oui
il est connu parce qu'en fait c'est un
pâtissier de luxe sérieux bailly bosse
dans des hôtels de luxe
il fait des truites magnifique mais
attends c'est ouf ça c'est à dire que ça
fait ça fait donc on joue ensemble il ya
toujours pas et toujours par un éclair
au chocolat rien la norma ce cas là
dessus il ya actuellement le japon
ah merde battu il a une page facebook
si vous voulez voir ces trucs une page
proulx benjamin lagarde
ah ouais non mais il est vraiment chaud
de shipshaw quoi elle est chaud les
choses aillent danser vous faites là
c'est marrant ça aide beaucoup plus
intéressant que joueur d'échecs en plus
abeilles allez c'est génial en fait ils
voyagent partout je traverse que
prochain speech on va l'inviter quand
même très intéressant avant de tuer 1800
c'est très bien on va parler pâtisserie
et bonne bouffe coiffage et on dit très
intéressé ici grand maître pâtissier
ah ouais c'est ouf ça assez cool assez
cool de chez coule pas il ya déjà la
page et où tu as ta ludovic chudy lui de
fixer un bon c'est là c'est le patron tu
allais déjà trouvé la page la page
facebook il en train de déjà de préparer
un montage d'ailleurs sur ton très la
sspc vous vous pouvez voir les photos
c'est très beau si fier a dû compter
étoile ils te mettent des pousses bleu
et tout est fantastique il ya plein de
plein de petits diot qui va être des
pousseurs c'est peut être surpris ces
mecs très très con qui joue aux échecs
ils sont tous là rennes en fantastique
fantastic on apprend des choses du cou
et dont il était il était dans les 1800
payet dans les 1800 et le dans les
jambes
un toit c'est un truc qui m'a toujours
étonné genre au tennis talent et soeurs
plus puisque aura je pense je sais pas
si tu connais et en fait elles sont
jumelles donc tu dis jumelles
enfin tu dis jumelles d'avoir à peu près
le même niveau et on a une qui est
numéro trois mondial qui était numéro un
mondial est à l'autre qui est numéro 85
mois alors qu'est ce qui se passe en
m'ont donné tu vois tes genre
physiquement l'appareil entre les
jumeaux t genre 100 % identique x 1
et qu'est-ce qu'il allait abandonner
quoi pourquoi y est question de mental
mais on a les mêmes dans les échecs ne
l'effraie rigal qu ils sont jumeaux
virgile galko je crois qu'il sera
jumeaux a en tout cas ils se ressemblent
à ça mais tant qu est ce que ces
engagements il y en a qui étaient 26 70
c'est l'autre qui est 25 50 depuis
toujours mais tu te demande qu'est ce
qui se passe un moment donné quoi
pourquoi y en a un qui décolle autant et
l'autre bon je sais pas non mais bien
sur l'environnement c'est doux c'est un
truc toujours c'est un truc toujours
étonnant donc du coup cette position il
se passe exactement ce que la tue à dire
elle le sauve qui n'a pas réussi à
obtenir du contre jeu suffisant chose
cercle s'ils récupèrent des cinq y aura
égalité matérielle mais les pions blancs
ça va faire cas là je pense que c'est
foutu
c'est foutu je pense déjà donc là il
faut voir si un peu fou prend les quais
c'est sale et il ya d'hommes ces six ans
qu'elle prend des cinq dames prend des
singes mais ça doit être perdu donc
quand même bah ça y'a un truc qui me dit
que c'est perdu et métiers projet
regroupe précieux c'est ce qu'était jeu
ouais vous prend b3 bah ça tu as assez
mais les attend ils peuvent à faire dame
prend b3 gamme c6 dame b 8 échecs ça
c'est michel sas et humble à temps mais
dan salas à monsieur oui tu es fou du 8
mai il ya six à peyrecave attend dame
ses huit dames n'importe où dans une c4
ces deux des huit à six français 7 à 7 à
ok
il va y avoir une déviation va le voir
car il a fait un oui du coup il n'a pas
fait dame s'est vite il a fait dame
prend 1,5 direct qui est des cinq dames
eu un mois j'ai deux dames e4 marais pas
juste dame f3 et la finale et peut-être
pas si simple à gagner chez pas su
d'abeilles strange et c'est très simple
tu as de prendre j'ai 84 et tout sera
visible un talent fou qui m arrive en a
trois ouais
le roi qui va arriver en dessin il
commence comme en sport ou fin quand
même parce que pour moi ça me vide et
gagner dans les quatre plus lente
ouais après franchement je m'inquiète
pas franchement je m'inquiète pas là tu
récupères des six aux forces
voilà bon courage et de 5-fu à trois
fonds d'investissement bon le chinois
qui mène oui 2 1
j'ai envie de te dire c'est un peu et
c'est contre le cours du jeu
alors on ne sait pas pourquoi c'est
contre le cours du jeu mais voilà parce
que y'en a un qui est français donc
automatiquement il est plus fort mais
bon on n'y peut rien par l'agencé ont
fait pas exprès je dis toujours tu vois
on est français on fait pas exprès est
ce que tu vois ce que je veux toute
l'équipe vous prendra mais j'adore cette
variante pouvait quatre échecs roi des
huns sais pas si tu saches que je
connais pas tu joues pas le système de
londres aussi
non mais c'est pas une mauvaise marion
qui va vouloir faire genre fou des
trois-rois eux deux non mais ça va pas
leur mauvais goût c'est un peu
surprenant de base ccb 4e non tu prends
de l'espace et 5b 4d 3 à 2 après tu vous
peut être mais rica 3-2 bon voilà donc
automatiquement il fait autre chose mais
messi s'est imposé qu'un parent ayant
peu importe on a pu les calmes des
joueurs parce qu'elle est belle il est
plus expressif je sais pas si tu peux
[Musique]
c'est pas moi qui ai fait la remarque
dans le chat parce que je les avais
j'avais perdu qu'elle est belle et plus
expressifs donc c'est plus intéressant à
regarder wave elle est marrant j'ai
encore dimanche oui par contre il faut
qu'il appelle jean michel cadrage
non mais j'en c'est complètement fou qu
en fait on va essayer on voit la moitié
de son visage passé je me cache
remarque on perd pas grand chose on perd
pas de mimiques nom pourri non mais
vaine chasse ça va venir
s'ils commencent pas gagner il va
s'énerver mais surtout qu'on avait
commenté un match de wailly ensemble et
il était là en mode
ouais il n'a pas vu six mois il n'a pas
vu ça c'est incroyable 5 watts qui l'a
fait la veille là il a un peu fait du
lad quoi ouais non c'est toujours plus
facile quand tu commentes de voir des
choses
j'étais choquée quoi mais après je
n'avais pas jusqu'à et b4 et prend des
trois et on s'est peut-être insp et un
pour les noms mais je pense que oui je
joue pas comme ça mais je pense que
c'est apple qui a validé 8e aller ou en
fait je pense qu'il veut changer les
quais ou 6 kg 5
et derrière hp g62 croisé cet ouvrage
suite j'ai pas mal ça comme plan moi
c'est pareil c'est pas bête sauf que
qu'elle g5 on peut mais non on est
obligé pont tu peux pas vraiment faire
d'attac de minorités toute façon non
mais là je pense que c'est juste honteux
nos rangs c'est bizarre quand on se fait
dominer par parrot ici pas normal quand
même non mais vous dormir est pas
mauvais ouais non il est pas mauvais il
est pas mauvais mais bon enfin j'ai
envie de dire enfin maxime vachier
lagrave
enfin jérôme ans et a même pas le droit
d'être devant normalement
tu vois tu tu te caches quoi on ne veut
plus te voir bon pour le moment on va
pas être méchant encore alors non on
peut être on va attendre un peu on n'est
pas encore mauvais perdants tu vois on
reste on reste correct mais faut qu'il
fasse quand même très attention où il
ici comment ça tu vas prendre troll
avantage ça peut partir tu vois là
bordeaux
le catch comprend peu à idron bah ouais
mais il pense aux dvd de vlad est ce
assez
depuis isolées très important voilà
contre le pion sais si je connais très
bien la structure battu voilà le roi un
f1 je sais pas je peux ouais mais il va
pouvoir faire des cinq dans tous les cas
à chalon y'a pas fou congé déjà c'est
quoi l'idée du cac et prend d'abord
gueule ok je suis parfois je cet échec
cavalière et ok quand tu feras g6 du
bailleur peut commencer les rangs des
idées ça va ça va
il est dans le dur en fait en fait il
est dans le dur en fait vraiment il est
donc du ralentissement non mais attends
c'est normal
arrivé au lycée pris comme ça dans mes
calculs hawaï et tu vas pas l'avoir adsa
ces deux jeux rentables se connaissent
très bien je veux on va montrer l'idée
quoi il veut faire prise prise du coup
il attaque là le mec fait un coup quoi
et surtout ces français très bas mais je
pense tour et puis ça suffit pas de
temps en fait c'est un peu de la merde
ok l'idée est pas débile non mais l'idée
pas bête mais attend il a fait quoi les
faits fouet cette direct ah c'est pas
bête fuglseth direct c'est - à - dire
elle veut faire qu'il prend baisse est
maintenant tournée c'est ouais mais il
va te prendre internationaux gc cinq ans
il va te prendre ici après amy est bon
ouais non mais bon je te dis calcul
quand c'est concret il trouvera ouais
enfin ça ne plaît pas trop l'un deux
points d'écart si maxime fo qui la sauve
salah enfin faut qu' il faut qu'ils nous
fassent quelque chose là parce que ça va
pas bien se passer s'ils n'ont pas bien
se passer
il peut encore comment
il peut la sauver oui kate est toujours
la seule c'est maxime vachier lagrave
les mecs me dire ça je pourrais parier
qu'il va pas la sauver mais ouais ouais
non mais bon après 1 mais ils arrivent à
réussir le roi de cette tour des six
tours points trois histoires de mais il
va faire tourner ses 6
ouais tu vas regarde non sérieux y va il
va y arriver on regarde sur cavaliers
aussi s'il va faire tourner cet échec il
va le mettre sur ma rivale mme et en
sueur franchement tu t'inquiètes pour
rien là tu t'inquiètes pour rien
regarde ce match tranquillement tu te
fais pas de souci
c'est plus calme at j'ai commenté comme
ça j lo mais quoi vous inquiétez pas
vous inquiétez pas vous inquiéter pas au
final on a perdu comme des merdes donc
enfin faut pas forcément mais je
m'inquiétais pas tu vois je n'étais
jamais inquiet au moins tu as peut être
qu'il a perdu parce que quand on joue en
pro de chez slick champ sur un camp je
vous regarde jouer vous m'inquiéter tout
le temps là je suis pas je suis pas
inquiet la liant il ya quand même une
grosse une grosse différence de classe
encore donc vous des six noms mais à
faire crisser 4 et savent à quoi bon
aller ça merde
quelques essais captons repenser 4 pas
trop ça
je ne m'inquiète pas on s'inquiète pas
on a un accord de pièces de moins non en
fait il est juste fou tu veux on a tu as
raison tu n'arrives non mais si oui j'y
gagne pas ce genre de pause il va pour
gagner beaucoup donc c'est parce que là
on le voit bien sur son visage que
maximy commence à suez la ben attia
marche ça va ça va être intéressant si
continent laisse comprendre alors que
oui ils sont fous total c'est la
sorcière et mais mc ça appartient non
mais il veut pas abandonner pour le
moment non mais c'est normal qu'ils
auront retenus par marc c'est normal
ça commence à faire beaucoup d'
entourage mais tout est stratégie du
coup parce que s'il sent qu'il est moins
fort dans l'écho dans les quatre ans un
peu plus lente
il va chercher à passer vite aux
cadences heures d'après ouais il veut il
peut essayer de jouer un peu la montre
mais bon peut-être je me trompe
qu'est-ce que ça se trouve maxime est
meilleure dans les cadences plus rapide
car je pensais pas qu'il allait
commencer comme ça c'est sûr pas mais
j'espère bien après oui il a pu se
préparer aussi pour le match tu vois
c'est là c'est possible m
ml je peux le lycée prépare et on joue
au tarot non ça c'est clair je sais pas
ce que j'ai fait avec une bouche c'est
toujours un client au tarot d'ailleurs -
non non non c'est moche et froid qui ont
été assorties de thé sortie de la zone
c'est bon je suis complètement sortie de
la zone ça va c'est une bonne nouvelle
du coup ces femmes maintenant clients
dans la bijouterie en le client scène
c'est le spécialiste de la grotte je
postule ouais je vois pas je le vois
mais c'est pas moi c'est l'autre d'avoir
spécialistes à et du coup ses clients il
faudra leur faire bientôt en trouver un
nouveau va pas durer longtemps
bon du coup là on a une dragonne dorff
bonjour non là on a le wef
l'âge d'or cage 3 c'est pas mal comme
système exercice au mexique pour le
monde cherche un système d'achat je
crois qu'ils cherchent son système il a
un système dans ses bases c'est
peut-être qu'il veut juste pas le sortir
même oui c'est sûr que maxime il va pas
jouer ses variantes numéro un pour pour
ce tournoi clairement non qu'il a sorti
la même elle est mince à y aller quand
ça arrange rien savoir
le match va tourner voir ça en tout cas
il n'y en a cinq cavaliers sur le bord
déjà donc très bien placé forcément du
coup on est bien mais c'est vrai que là
la diagonale du fou g7
ça se passe bien ouais ouais ça mc que
si tu te fais changer les crues des cats
a pas bien spéciale
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui leur arrive
et je ne peux pas faire genre cinq ans
piller
à quel dessein de hockey des 5 serge
lehman a tout fait si les six on peut
montrer pour lequel des cinq sa fille
manon
quel dessein que ça fait mal aux menaces
publicis qu'est-ce que ça peut bien sûr
car lycées 6 il a trouvé six ouais bah
est impressionnant loyer pendant ce
temps ça gagne juste non cahier des cinq
bateaux que ces six forcément aille à
tour ces systèmes
mais toutes ces 6 3 mais manque ou comme
cahier des cats ça va pas du tout il a
fait eu six si je voulais arrêter à
l'étranger 5 m bien joué
et du coup il ya eu aussi ce faux bond
aux 6 1 6 4 6 1 mais du coup du coup ci
c'est bien j'ai pas français ouais avec
le pion g5 pour ses sets et là il n'y a
pas d'âme prend des six qui a faut
prendre ça vaut quoi te faire rock ici
genre tu laisses à toi ça va être tour
où tu peux tout le temps à laisser ouais
ça joue sajou tranquille sa belle le fou
vol hors jeu - calida trop faible trop
marbre noir justement ça t'intéresse
haye a priori je pense que les contours
de compensation sont largement
suffisantes
tu peux pas bouger ne vois même pas
comment tu sauves le cas valence surtout
et trois breaks pour faire front aux
cinq mois je nourris ce qui se passait
sur dame c3 je n'arrive pas à voir
quelle ccist ait laissé six vous moi je
suis pas je suis dans le dur je voyais
pas revenir j'avais encore le résidu du
foot b6 de tout à l'heure qui me restait
en tête
ouais donc il revient en c6 et fouet il
faut être prêt à faire jusqu'à et g7
mais j'imagine le web et c'est pour ça
que je préférais jouer ff trop avec la
tour en un champ pour faire hhk taschen
derrière ça m'a l'air d'aller plus ou
moins quand même là pour maxime pensée
compliqué mais je n'ai pas peur que ce
soit mais je pense que les athlètes m-66
fait à fils il va réussir à colmater les
quinze mois cisco fleurs garde ce week
end et 5
et le thème qu'est des cinquièmes donc
tu veux dire que les cinq prises prime
valable parce que dame 18 trous mais si
si allez tu es tu encaisses la tour tu
vois peut-être que là déjà ça peut
marcher
ok l'aféas fils donc la question c'est
de savoir si qu'à valider cinq marches
qu'on va regarder puis on prend
cavaliers prend est ce que dame des
mythes c'est le seul coup non je suis
pas fils à tour je peux jouer damev 7
pions projet cinq équipes quatre ports
du velayat peut-être cinq fois c'est
avec fous des sécheries road avec
cavaliers c7 contrôler la case aussi
soit assez chaud il ya eu qu'à et des
cinq prises prise d'armé vii qui a hissé
sa table et cinq écoutes qui peut
s'asseoir à table le simple pour le
rejoindre cap le mans c'est tout ce que
tu as dit c'est la partie et si feu 5 je
pense que plus personne ne sait si à ta
table
je veux citer les cas tu sais pas encore
pas fini f5 avaler f4 qui contrôle la
casse des 5 mais bon allez on n'en prend
2 me prend dans les fourons dame profs
ou dessins qui a fait échec aussi avec
la dame a et u control tout eu contre la
dessécher perpète oui donc même si tu
fais tu montres injuste tu contrôles
cette diagonale cette colonne et mais tu
vois là encore tout reste rosstat
physique
porsche est au bout comme ça et pourquoi
pour jouer le père pète menace macd en
un espace adapté en force
elle attend ça peut-être la partie je
pense que ça va être la partie en
réalité bon il s'en tire bien maxime la
ci prend là nul sur celle-là peu sa
sortie qui peut s'asseoir à la table de
maxime lagarde et dire j'ai un meilleur
frères pâtissier que toi ah oui c'est
beau c'est beau en fait si la partie
elle se finit comme ça ouais ouais ok
mais il peut faire dam des deux
franchises nba il peut faire de moorea
mesdames b2fair la maison prendre son
temps toute façon tu as que roy justice
parce que si tu
il peut faire cavalier cinq ici il n'a
pas fait sur cavaillon 5 et sûrement
d'amd 4 on peut retourner voir la
variante est assez intéressant non mais
ça m'a l'air d'être
je pense à des coups comme dame 17h
ramener cueille mais n'ont pu se caler
contrôle des oui non changent pas alors
il a fait dame b 2 les cavaliers 5
c'est exactement la position à laquelle
on pensait cavalli g4 à temps il se
passe quoi sur bayal à tour des rangs
l'air cavaliers mais peut-être faire
d'alger cette voie ouais par exemple sa
seule sortie son bref comment cela va
tant que dames proches
non mais l'attelage toujours est deux
points fitch qu'on l'abandonné juste y
avait donc profité d'un prime fuite et
puis on change les quatre pays qui
réussissent donc écoute là là ça
commence à faire mal comme trois points
d'écart mais kevin on s'inquiète pas
c'est ce que dénonce souvent ignorée par
an 5 une part s'inquiète pas on
s'inquiète pas je sais pas pourquoi
enfin je comprends plus pour qu'on
s'inquiète pas maintenant là que tu vois
je toi tu étais déjà inquiète alors tu
vois j'ai essayé de tout âge et cgc de
maintenir les gens en bonne santé
mentale là ont mené un an mené 1-0 on
vient de se prendre 4 0 la 6e je
comprends plus là qu'est ce qui se passe
et on se croirait un match de ping pong
la bête quand on sait que je vais
contrats chinois au ping pong c'est pas
bon signe en club bah justement
oui s'il te fait sa prise de raquette la
chinoise et ils t'envoient des balles à
effet et une fumée plus un point en fait
mais bon c est ce que c'est pas interdit
de jouer comme ça on ne sait pas c'est
quoi le tee shirt de maxime la scène
c'est un tee shirt qui porte la poisse
et un trucs écrits on va pas trop ses
écrits quoi monsieur calais le montre
l'écran baisser voire riga greengard ça
votre t-shirt du grand prix grand pré à
dire j'ai envie de te dire mais la gagne
en plus maniable et perdu dans mes
effets finale il a perdu à riga contre
mam est en finale aouidat perdu c'est
pas le mont t-shirt là faut qu'il faut
lui dire de mettre un tueur bitstream
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est pour
remonter je pense est la seule chance si
jamais pour lui écrire sur facebook car
bon train pas de chance ton t-shirt puis
la défaite ça ne sera pas là mais enfin
là encore pourquoi il joue ce genre de
truc quoi je sais pas ce qu'ils
cherchent pourquoi je le revois pas le
cas tu vois là ou alors ils cherchent à
se faire éliminer à peut-être il donne
un truc de créer eu le job davies y
voilà j'ai les grands prix je me faire
je vois pas d'autre explication que ce
moment perdre contre eux oui sans le
faire exprès tu vois j'ai envie de te
dire il ya un problème il pourrait
perdre les pédales gros score qu un
point d'écart bah justement là il va
remonter c'est pas possible
non mais peut-être il est juste pas en
forme il a beaucoup joué dernièrement il
a joué le grand dauphin il a joué le
grand prix le grand jet tours paris le
grand jet tours saint louis la sinne que
phil cup
il n'arrête pas de jouer ont peut-être
il juste il a l'air de toi tu veux
combien de tournois par an maxime agent
fait énormément
[Musique]
juste des tournois open
on va faire 15 entre 10 et 15 juin donc
tu joues tu joues rien qu en open
130 140 partie par an ouais je suis
facile à 100 participants sans sans
compter on est d'accord sans compter les
tops des trucs et tu joue par équipe
mise à part nice je jouais à l'étranger
j'ai une équipe en espagne
j'ai une équipe en belgique et j'ai joué
quelques matchs en pays bas et donc été
quasiment toujours en train de tourner
en train de jouer les week-ends je suis
souvent en déplacement et ses cantons
prochain tour elle a par exemple tu
viens de revenir de chartes il ya une
semaine je vais peut-être jouer à
barcelone fin septembre ouais
et sinon je vais aller jouer en corse le
corsica
ouais ça c'est du rapide ça voilà c'est
le rapide un beau tournoi j'imagine ça
c'est vraiment bien mais j'avais fait
jamais finir finalement dernier et c'est
ouais c'est vraiment bien comme toi et
après le chant pas d'or et le
championnat d'europe donc tu espères
gagné il ya une place pour une coupe du
monde ou non le champion d'europe par
équipes ah oui avec la france sur
l'aliment d'europe individuel c'est l'an
prochain c'est ça avec une place à
prendre en garantie allemand pour vous
la coupe du monde qui aura lieu
d'ailleurs dans de lundi ça commence
lundi la coupe du monde
ouais bon donc à un emploi du temps
chargé mais peut-être pas aussi chargé
que les joueurs de haut niveau et y joue
encore plus j'ai l'impression aux noms
j'en emploi du temps beaucoup plus
chargé que les jours de yum tu penses à
huy en talent sur l'année oui après
c'est pas laissez pas les mêmes tons
mats mais c'est je joue plus que ça
c'est sûr l'adapt est une période très
méritant une grosse période en ce moment
la râpe réveil sont mises en cause
pilotent c'est sûr là ils sont mais
après tu vois c'est je paye jour kouassi
tournois par an ou 7 à +1 juste plus
maintenant bas étaient avec les ont ils
ont trois grands prix déjà donc t'es
jamais alors que maxime il a trois grand
prix
la coupe du monde on est soit il a
quatre tournois fidh qualificatif haut
au canada et après il doit jouer
peut-être trois grandes chaînes tour en
longue je pense il a joué la croatie il
a joué saint louis il va sur un os x qui
joue pas mais le sien il sera qualifié
et après ils ont tous les rapides rapide
ebit sur cinq jours il en rejouant
encore 3 ou 4 3 peut-être mais ça sature
et ses joyeux compagnons d'échappée
ouais c'est vrai que ça joue sajou plus
que hay fossé faut se les farcir quand
même un peu naïve où il joue vraiment
beaucoup mais la maxi 1000 et bien non
de cette partie enfin ils à leur bureau
c'est pas trop comment ça s'est passé
mais il a réussi à taper un pion de la
réussi à atteindre à taper des trucs ils
à leurs biens ce que je trouve un cool
prévisions puis bon il a un pion plus
toujours le pion à ses 5 îles égard à
cela il a gagné sa main complètement
gagnant c'est chez les ménages font
effet à l'élan milan bouffe à foison
quoi il va sortir son jus bientôt je
vous quand ça se passe mal et mlm s'est
vu quand ça se passe bien où je ne mange
pas je ne fume économistes quoi me
manquer c'est cette e-menace la dame
onces par verre ou bombay bk tombe tu
attaques leucate haussier au passage
c'est pas mal ça ouais ça a l'air d'être
bien joué mais peut-être fait cavalier à
6 mais tu prends encore madame dati en
g14 bêtement fouet 5
il a pris bien en premier cavalier à
fait ce qui protège le pion avait la
tour des six pôles où tu menaces qu avec
tour des six je prends juste de l'espace
jeunesse ou des cats qui a ses trois il
veut manger il veut manger la pièce
d'intelligent tout dépend s'il y arrive
concrètement ou par là après jamais
facile ce genre de coup quand tu
commentes a vraiment voir parce que t'as
pas le temps qu'elle voulait précisément
donc tu as du mal à savoir menacés chez
5 à 3 sur gsm c'est un coût auquel on
pense pas et cavaliers parce qu'on ferme
et il veut faire qui est des cinq
attaques et chez les dames chez soi que
c'est bien j'ai juste un peu machiste
hockey des cinq décès donc ils menacent
la dame le pion et le fou non c'est pour
ça c'est trop ces trois sites est
peut-être un peu trop passif fallait
être plus directe ur des six coups des
quatre ans car il peut avoir du foot
français 3 et d'un moulage 4 et prend ou
là où l'on attendait pas fou aussi juste
et un mail à sa fille et à chypre
non juste ashes fouquereau h 3o schiste
voilà je sis tu as raison s'agit de les
débats ce qu'est ce qui fait maxime
l'axé laisse vite on n'a pas compris
moi je comprends pas le délire en fait
mais non mais c'est là je comprends plus
là c'est catastrophique géant va être
mené de quatre points par capoue ben oui
et après lui mais rend au niveau du
temps il joue trop vite je comprends pas
pour jouer et jouer aussi vite
il joue à toute blinde mais il l île à 3
minutes d'avancé mais il est
complètement père dont il ya pas de
calais face il est vrai à en pâtir
il est dans le dur là qu'est ce qui fait
chuter il va perdre et c'est pas
possible
là il a l'air fatigué rien su quoi et tu
allais quand ça se fait à essayer
commence à jouer la scandinave sas et
bientôt maman la grotte je vais dire de
prendre du jus tu peux lui écrire un
wave après non mais il va dire je pense
à la mi-temps à une mi-temps entre les
truites en trois minutes way ou cinq
minutes je sais pas
non mais ça va pas d'être menés de
quatre points qu'est ce qui se passe là
non plus je te dise on sait c'est hyper
bizarre ses choix son jeu ses choix
c'est très bizarre
même quand tu regardes c'est son visage
il est là il a plus du tout l'air serein
j'ai des petits gestes de visage fait
d'être lemire houle un peu les yeux on
croirait kasparov hier soir quoi de
niort parce que ça m'a dit vas-y
non mais je dis à l'autre ça se voit
qu'il est très concentré genre il joue
très sérieusement mon avis le petit
joueuses qui jouent habituellement et
maxime chez pas ils tentent des trucs ce
qu'on dit le scandinave des trucs qui
jouent pas habituellement je comprends
pas pourquoi pourquoi il fait ça devrait
après il ya des grosses échéances à
venir
non mais je sais dire mille est pas
obligé de sortir ces nouveautés jouer
simplement uqat et oui toujours normal
genre ça c'est des ouvertures qui sont
bien gilad sur wii via tout il ya trop
de temps faut espérer que qui remonte
clairement dans les cadences plus rapide
de toute façon si vous videz qui joue
comme ça ça va pas trop le pénaliser
d'avoir d'avoir trois minutes 1 après ça
j'ai remonté 1,4 point ça se remonte
mais là il est juste un peu moins bien
mais il n'a pas totalement tort réside
chez bien résumé ouais bon résumé de
risi tchèque doit être un commentateur
de qualité d'ailleurs c'est vrai que ils
nous disent est ce que la scandinave
c'est une mauvaise ouverture je te
laisse répondre parce que tu es tu à
l'impartialité avec c'est objectivement
pas extraordinaire après ça peut être
pas mal un certain niveau je pense que
c'est pas mal mais alors niveau s'est
passé fabrice ya trop de trop de lignes
qui sonne bien pour les blancs ouais
mathieu il m'a dit qu'il pouvait à faire
il pouvait la faire tenir de partout
mais il ya beaucoup de choses à
connaître tu peux tu peux aller moins
bien partout en fait on met je peux
faire tenir n'importe quelle ouverture
avec un ordinateur mais quand tu es
obligé de te connaître toutes les lignes
parker c'est un job
ouais c'est jouable en rapide en fait je
pense même même un certain niveau parce
que c'est une ouverture un peu surprise
ouais pas plus en fait c'est intéressant
d'un scandinave quand les mecs avec les
blancs rentrer dans les variantes chaude
donc cherché à réfuter tout de suite là
ça devient intéressant parce que ces
ouvertures de comptes
mais si juste les blancs jouent
simplement pas de problème si les blancs
on veut juste jouer à
je vois un truc et gagnent enfin ou même
100 m ouais c'est sarens en parlait
d'égal juste un petit plus solide c'est
très très désagréable je pourrais normes
oui non ils peuvent obtenir ça dans
plusieurs variantes et sans aucun
problème après c'est vrai que quand il
essaye de prendre l'avantagé vraiment te
punir là ça peut être chaud parce que tu
vois des rocs opposé ça peut être étendu
ce cas là tu vois ça ça pose sa voix pas
idiot encore par la food & 5 il est
monstrueux non iapr de fou fou descendre
monstrueux et le roi et fiable le renoir
ayant un pion passé et enfin il y en a
un qui est en c5 et il ya l'autre il ne
cessa sais même pas s'ils jouent en fait
ils haïssent dit oui bon bafouée ce que
je dois partir les mecs ou pas attention
à enfin il y en a planté une mince et a
fini dans ces simples qu'elle a fait un
petit un petit visage de deux release me
disent les anglais ça va tu as ta le
pion d'à côté qui de la scandinave a
permis de passer de 9 de 450 à 900 donc
je pensais que c'était bien mais un
certain niveau je pense que c'est pas
mal passée de 450 à 900 il a doublé ces
points l'eau tu aurais dit toi essaye de
le faire j'essaye de passer de 2006 à
5200 là comme quoi donc
ils nous proposent d'amd 8 qui menace le
fou de la tactique indemne des victimes
et à slash ou qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
avec les blancs et ce qui risque à
quelque chose pour les blancs ça a l'air
d'être sympa tâche tout ça
ça m'a l'air d'être cool là je vois pas
comment comme la dame qui a attaqué
peut-être fou p3 et forcé news
[Musique]
ok vous voulez froid tu mens juste la
dame non nous et j'ai c'est qu'on
pratique jours et la matière un coup
comme fumée passive alors menace déjà
tout reprend 1,3 et dames français 5 mai
mais là ça va mais là ça va évidemment
pas ces pièces de plus après faut pas la
rater
mais encore un micro c'est peut-être pas
encore serait peut-être pas encore si
simple en dame assise karim c'est cette
malle pioncer est dangereux quand même
temps on voit plus wailly tu peux pas
juste décalé un peu le jeu est un peu
baissé le truc que je mette ça comme ça
on va bien le comptable c'est parfait
pour ses sets
sur fouet 4 faut faire gaffe parce que
tu peux pas caler deux cavaliers ou 5
vous prend vous prend et adam c4 qui
rôde
du coup il veut faire quoi sur foued 4 4
4 dans la tour des quatre mois pour ces
4 mai tour des quatre
[Musique]
autour des quatre c4 après tu pourras
calais en cavale et un retour des quatre
tours c'est cote la cession tu peut-être
faire d'enfant crise prises tijd nom de
taken a été cloué rsa est un peu chiant
ok c'est la partie d'ailleurs il faut
voir ça tourne un geste non tourte moins
jusqu'à ce qu'on ait pu faire tourner
ses 8
ouais mais tous ces huit heures c'est
cette fois il va vous la faire dame à 6
mais tu pourras bloqué avec dame 17
ouais mais tu vois là tu es dans une
position où tu t'es fort
oui mais si tu as réussi graduellement à
wayne est rare dame française j'essaie
de garder mon fiancé en plus ton roi non
je pense que il était tellement mal que
c'était pas si simple à gagner malgré le
le cadeau quoi habituel fait pas la tête
des grands jours mais même dans ces
temps normal il a pas il a vraiment pas
leur sort
je suis quand même une grosse surprise
en hausse et pas de temps une grosse
surprise
d'hawaii kembs à ses joueurs
certainement mais bon maxime vachier
lagrave les mecs comme toi tu vois là
même un coup comme fou alors je pensais
à foug g5 damgan d'un v6 mais attends je
vais montrer parce que ça c'est
n'importe quoi
mais il ya tout repenser cette et ya
même des oui c'est vraiment n'importe
quoi
c'est complètement je voulais juste dire
que la tour n'avait plus qu'à se
prononcer s'ils commencent par damas six
intermédiaires je pense qu'il ya tout ce
qu'on sait c'est aussi non ouais ouais
ok il a peut-être trouvé un truc là
maxime quand même parce que si les
changes les fous ça va ça va aller
beaucoup mieux ouais ouais parce que le
pion cespa ferme hqe est
sur bam 17 il veut quoi qui a aidé 6ème
et 5ème j'avais pas vu bon là du coup la
radio du coup ils commencent à
consolider il peut même essayer
d'attaquer peut-être que le cueille à
nantes cavaliers libre mais faut faire
gaffe autre dame ait quoi que ça va
aller j'ai utilisé peut-être d'un match
4 da madame des huit ans moment donné
pour faire un père pète façon les blancs
ils ont quoi comme idée ici il peut pas
vraiment créé et de menaces non non non
non ils doivent attendre
bon là il menace la tour et
éventuellement le pion mais bon faut
trouver un truc pour avancer bahdja ça
se ça se calme que tu vas perdre c'est
cet art au g8 donne ses cotes
mais parker et léa fille 6 du coût non
cash is that the gods calmes
ouais il y avait les f-5 après plein la
culture a donc tour ccist j'ai réussi à
la faire coulisser latour jeu d'attaqué
justice ouais ouais ouais on remet
évidemment évidemment la police on doit
être mieux pendant les accalmies une
pièce de plus puis bon il a il a du
temps avance aussi petites nanas sont
pas seules menaces prises crise est
double attaque
on demande si tu penses que maxime peut
gagner le tour un des candidats s'y
qualifient oui oui non mais bien sûr je
pense que tous nous tout le monde peut
le gagner dans le top niveau
je tiens un tournoi qui est très
homogène très ouvert je me serais
peut-être une pièce sur d'hingham qui
semble être en forme
ouais mais même dink street ou vendent
c'est le premier en plus à mettre en
difficulté magnus dans les dents les
départage depuis longtemps donc oui en
plus solide à faire ça semble prouver
qu'il a des nerfs d'acier
ouais après une belle william bell
pourquoi c'est bien là ce qu'a fait oui
n'empêche n'a battu voix il
le poste de torcé 5 cm à me prendre en
russie ces chèques et la perpète à terme
il doit être aux 1 cuil et donc on va
permettre bref cette ces six dames bien
et chaque femme 17
c'est imparable bon 5 2 ça on revient
regarde ça et maxime là il est content
il souffle un peu mais c'est plutôt bon
signe ça peut partir de là il a
peut-être besoin de se débloquer allez
l'afo faut y aller là il reste combien
de temps dans la cadence il ya 119
minutes il reste il reste deux parties
je voudrais tourner à -2 6 tournois - 2
c'est bien oui - 2 ça va quoi après la
cadence après il ya une heure en train
de plus en trois juste en trois plus un
secret une heure en 3 + 1 et après il ya
trente minutes en un +11 plus en plus
c'est pas du bullet c'est quoi mais à
meyrin +1 tu peux tu peux gagner le
match de 4 5 points vraiment l'argent si
tu commences à enchaîner en fait tu peux
tu peux vite faire + 4 + 5
donc même si tournant 3 + 1 à - 2 - 3 il
sera toujours dans le match quoi par la
cie se ressaisit toute façon ça va il ya
trois points d'écart c'est loin d'être
une cata cette position ça vaut quoi tu
connais un petit peu je connais pas
particulièrement je te dis théoriquement
je suis pas la pointer non après ça
aurait pu être dressé une position
classique mais la saveur parce que sur
québec pour bamba k way salaire de
salage a pas bon pour les pour les
neurones la dame elle doit les mini des
cavaliers à 3 la dame de l'es8 b5
yaakaar l'a31 mais ce genre de pollution
et mieux je pense qu'elle est déjà pas
bonne parce que l'écart est à trois
quand même et surtout prend b2 il ya
kelly c4 double attaque et toutes les
pièces sont sortis de l année blanche a
une bonne tête
il faut qu'ils marquent que maintenant
et c'est bon on est revenu mais faudrait
qu'ils marquent vite celle là qui la
rend martin d'ary peut faire mieux on
lui en veut pas ils peuvent rester des
cavaliers b5 fou prend des cinq
cavaliers c'est cette eau si ben alaya
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de menaces là
c'est pour ça que je pense que la
position n'est déjà pas bonne parce que
normalement tu as au moins une pièce
sortie en plus pour elle en aura au
moins gagné ses six sorties tueur alors
on nous demande on l'a fait bonjour et
félicitations donc à toi pour la
victoire au championnat de la rance
et c'est quoi comme tournoi si c'en est
un basset c'est le speech championship
un tournoi organisé par chase comme qui
a un genre de on va dire championnat du
monde officieux de partie en rapide et
blitz sur internet
donc voilà peu près à tous les meilleurs
joueurs qui participent sauf sauf le
meilleur en fait sauf marquer plus on va
dire que ça joue la deuxième place
bad ternaux peut-être cavell est
amoureux n'a pas la tête à ça
oui c'est possible on sait pas on sait
pas qu'est ce que maxime a ressenti
avant les départage contre laurent ça
c'est pour toi comme question en
question de en tout 42 210 beaucoup de
stress juste avant le départage beaucoup
de stress beaucoup de fatigue aussi
parce que après une semaine de tomber
comme ça c'est juste épuisé et ouais
beaucoup de stress surtout et beaucoup
de tu disais tu mise avant le live tu te
sentais beaucoup mieux après avoir perdu
la première quelques poneys
on va faire du le stress c'est un peu
comme dans les exaltés ce très stressé
avant et tu vois là pour le reste on ne
sait pas faire les appels pour moi
j'étais moins stressé tu vois que tu as
compris que td td dur finir tu penses à
ce que tu as mangé le sort s'est passé
là ça s'est mieux passé parce que je
suis j'ai plus rien à perdre mais par
contre je me suis jamais dit c'est pas
retenu ce sac j'étais plutôt fier de moi
un truc fait très heureux oui
et c'est surtout que j'ai pas j'ai pas
abandonné mais même après avoir perdu
contre fraysse la deuxième partie du
championnat
je me suis pas dit ok c'est fini j'ai
plus aucune chance tu vois j'ai dit
allez on reste concentré et ça va le
faire et du coup quand a réattaqué les
blitz après avoir égalisé tu avais plus
ce stress que tu as vod blanche et non
là j'étais déjà en voie de roue libre
c'est déjà bien et la dernière partie
avec les blancs et s'est très bien passé
nous on n'a pas trop pu la voir parce
qu'il y avait des problèmes avec les pgm
ouais mais on a imaginé que tu as tout
était très bien
ouais je connaissais l'ouverture et il
connaissait pas trop j'avais déjà joué
ça contre an prochain ce leader contre
tarja riant donc voilà ce que j'étais
plus à l'aise et j'ai joué plus vite et
on te pose la question qui fâche sur les
trois fois la même position
enfin cinq fois la même la même alors
ouais alors ça c'est on va tuer cinq
fois la même pétition pour moi non oui
il 5 quand même position au bout de cinq
fois pour moi leur bille qui doit
intervenir ça passe à la règle après ce
qu'on a lui aussi après je veux pas me
prononcer parce que ça arbitres mais
d'après ce que je sais moi ça va donc
personne intervenait j'avais j'avais
plus de temps jeu de seconde de jeu et
évidemment quand à deux secondes que tu
as la pression du truc il n'y a pas eu
cinq fois on nous dit il n'y a pas eu
cinq fois
ok ok bon bref avec la pression du truc
et du temps j'ai pas eu le réflexe
d'arrêter la pendule puis dire je vais
jouer ce coup là tu vois j'ai eu ce coup
là et j'ai arrêté la contenu de son
appui dont il s'est interdit et donc du
coup ces trucs illégal donc laurent a
réclamé gilles abier roazhon d'ailleurs
c'est illégal
ils apprennent été très fair play il n'a
pas voulu changer son coup mais pour moi
ouais c'est dans ma tête c'est cinq fois
donc je comprenais pas que personne
n'attend après il n'a pas eu il n'avait
pas trop le choix non 200 s'il pouvait
faire
l'autre coup d'un le casse de ross était
plus chaud mais ne l'a pas fait il a été
très fort club peut aimer du coup qu'est
ce que tu aurais dû faire pour faire un
nul il fallait que tu arrêtes la pendule
que tu dises arbitres que taher mais
j'aurais dû arrêter la pendule au moment
de jeu dan des cats et dire je vais
jouer dam des quatre ce que j'ai fait
c'est que j'ai je vais peut-être des
quatre j'ai arrêté la production à
appuyer était le savez ça allait trop
vite avait pas le temps de réfléchir
ouais c'est un fait ça dans le feu de
l'action et dans le feu de l'action je
suis dit ok je sais que je dois papier
sans la pendule
mais tu as oublié qu'il fallait arrêter
la pendule avons en plus je connais la
suite on la connaît tous la règle un
truc voilà voilà voilà ce qui s'est
passé et en plus j'étais un peu énervé
du coin du coup comme j'ai arrêté la
prudence reste une seconde et je devais
ras puis sur la pendule à une seconde tu
as en jeu sans jouer le coup tu vois je
devais juste rappuyer et donc si j'avais
été un dixième de seconde je tombais
heureusement c'était une seconde pleine
j'ai eu le temps d'appeler se reprendre
mais j'aurais pu juste tombé comme ça
perdre la partie des pigments rsa aurait
été idiot et savait plus que 15
centièmes et en a pas eu le temps
ouais tu vois un centième je n'avais pas
le temps un disait quoi le temps le jeu
c'était beau c'était chaud mais du coup
ça c'est un des gros tournant du 1 et
c'était du plus dodue +1 c'était du 3
puces de je crois oui non si tu joues un
coup sûr récupère quand même deux
secondes ce qu'en trois ans avec +1 en
fait tu remontes jamais hein c'est sûr
que non mais là j'ai joué mon cou il a
prié le tout de suite je ne peux être
très sympa très cool ouais c'était
s'était pas de chance en fait tu aurais
dû continuer à faire les échecs comme ça
et être sûr qu'ils aient cinq fois
d'après ben oui j'aurais j'aurais pu
mais pousse t ça va tellement vite
est il déjà dix fois je ferai dans le
feu de l'action la pression et le moment
ça se passe de nouveau pas super bien
pour maxime non j'ai l'impression que
bon ça va la position mais finalement il
était tellement bien que
on aurait pu penser qu'ils obtiennent
plus voilà il ya un an leur hausse est
sûre ça pas l'air d'être non plus khatam
et wes paca tonnes par rapport à ce
qu'ils avaient tout à l'heure c'est vrai
je commence à pas le sentir du tout ce
match en fait maxime b nom soit gros
show on s'inquiète pas on s'inquiète pas
mais là c'est dans le contenu tu vois
c'est quand tu commences à pas réussir à
obtenir grand chose à la sortie de
position d'ouverture pareil c'est pas
bon signe non mais il n'a pas des
renforts en vue d'ailleurs fatigue vient
des états unis où il jouait la laci que
fils de sa s'est terminée quand c'est
terminé ya ya ya ya même pas une semaine
s'est terminée jeudi dernier je crois
oui il est rentré à bon temps est ce que
tu t'es déjà en brouille avec un joueur
à la fin d'une partie genre la page
voilà c'est tu trouve qu'il a un mauvais
comportement et oui ce soir sans doute
trop et j'ai pas d'exemples comme ça
mais oui je sais c'est sûr que wim
essais des embrouilles vraiment qui
durera près ou c'est juste des petites
embrouilles de fin de partie
tu dis ce que tu as à dire ça dure
quelques heures et je trouve un exemple
mais me connaissant c'est sûr que oui
mais rien de sérieux quoi number one
sérieux jean lemay qui lui en veut pas à
vie non
bassil mec est désagréable et
insupportable pour un parti généralement
je lui dis ce que je fais que ceux qui
fixent souvent c'est que c'est que
j'arrête de regarder la pression et je
le fixe pendant 20 secondes même si ils
baissent les yeux tu as fait tes peurs
celle d histoire de montrer que je peux
faire ça aussi toute la nuit si tu as tu
en as tu as des joueurs qui font ça
beaucoup de gens qui fixe la haye c'est
relou ça allait on a plein qui le font
c'est franchement c'est pas viable ouais
mais je sais pas s'ils le font pour pour
pour que soient désagréables pour toi ou
cissé je sais pas si j'ai pas vu mais on
a beaucoup qui le font ça reste
concentré p1 le 6 g paris pense
peut-être qu'il prenne une supériorité
ou c'est parce qu'ils pensent faire en
faisant ça mais bon c'est vrai que c'est
pas je trouve que c'est pas très correct
non non mais je voudrais enfin si tu
avais droit lui en coller une en fait
non mais tu vois dans ces cas là je vous
demande qu'on assume à fond tu vois si
le mec qui fait ça mais que la loi de
lui mettre une droite juste comme ça tu
es au passage dans ces cas là ce serait
moins dérangeant qui dirait bon c'est un
combat de boxe pourquoi pas quoi alors
maxime il va la gagner celle-là passé
tant pour wiggins
ouais des chances finales de cavaliers
c'est jamais facile à défendre dia les
pions doubler ici un f5 apsys il ya le
roi mieux placé je vois pas où il a
sauvé bon il va rester combien de temps
la suite de ça là il restera neuf
minutes donc y aura assez de temps pour
enfin de toute façon en fait la partie
des butins quoi qu'il en soit même s'il
restait deux secondes et on va jusqu'à
la fin mais il restera du temps pour une
partie ok normal al assad longuet bon
c'est pas moins de ce scrutin
et je pense que faire roi b6 d'ailleurs
là qu'elle prend f4r à cinq je vois pas
comment dans le lhc gagne sinon au moins
deux il en reste une
il suffit de la gagner c'est bon en fait
ils repassent à -1 et il est dans le
match
regardez sur le fait à chaque fois un
des noms mais ils souffrent pas et saufs
à il souffre pas évident alors faut que
ça change un peu des trois pas de 3d
soir par thierry jousse elle avait que 5
h 5
finalement c'est peut-être salle où il
est où il a été le mieux web ont vite
fait il alors je m'étais très bien mais
vous salue à vue qu'à rallier des
synchros marque lancel ou voyons pas bon
alors à temps cette fois ci avec b 6 rue
bessette donc toujours les mêmes plans
c'est les noirs qui attaqua les droits
et les blancs qui note la carelle dame
toujours la même chose en fait on essaie
de fixer les cases noires sur les droits
et cachent quatre mois et des changes
d'échangés de fougasses marek fou
j'ai cinq pas dans le piège c'est fou
j'ai cinq à quoi tu fais qualifie kg si
tu comptes contre la case acteurs donc
on veut jouer sur les 15 ans autour du
roi voilà on cherche à affaiblir le
roman le roi blanc mâle et ouais et
malgré le pion h5 le roi noir et pas si
faible que ça allez les noirs normands
bien solides de ce côté là pour ses
choeurs c4 provoque b3 je suppose
d'affaiblissement
mais ce que tu pourras du cac et prend
1,4 qui marche
quelque part je la tue ménages qui est
maintenant oui est une menace majeure
cif et b3 avec la tour en prie je pense
pas non non je pense pas ça très sympa
mais bon tu peux vouloir un truc comme
dame ces huit pays c'est ce un non-match
drogue damas huit tours s'est vite
4 tu t'en prends ac34 ces deux tu t'en
prends à tous en fait il faut jeu très
précis genre de poste parce que si tu
joues damas huit drogue pour celui tu
vas apprendre qu'il y ait des 5 es là tu
es pièce à ce qu'on lit par mal placé
une fois arrivé très précis tour des ans
toujours faire gaffe hockey et points 4
donc là il veut à avec les blancs il
veut jouer qu'il y ait des cinq dans le
bon tempo mais pas directement parce que
sinon il va se mettre ces pièces en pls
en gros on sera sûr qu'elle ait des cinq
là qu'il prend des cinq là est le fou
j'ai cinq restants prise de choix c'est
d'amérique
donc là prochain tour c'est huit silos
de fait rien ouais bah pas approcher
fouet watching et pour les quatre
manches pub ouais
cette tour c8 et cavalli a fui tout
coeur et les quais baïkal fuite il va
peut-être faire fou prend et machin donc
c'est exactement ce que tu nous dises
rapatriement je te dis ouais bah oui tu
fais quoi tu prends des cinq là non
quand même ouais mais tu prends un quoi
mais je n'aime pas les noirs encore si
tu prends du jeu auquel tu prends du fou
au québe 5 donc il veut empêcher ces
quatre épreuves
retour ces 8e moi j'ai du mal à
comprendre ses positions moi ça me
paraît bien pour les noirs mais je joue
tellement jamais ça et toi ça te paraît
bien pour les blancs bateau e dan des
trois fois je crois tu vois tu as si tu
venais de fou ok mais tour c'est 8 tu va
dépendre comment le pion jajpur la
colonne déjà après comme l'a donc tour
s'est vite tu vas juste couvrir avec un
tour à deux ou quelque chose comme ça ah
ouais non mais les jeux même tour à deux
tout de suite tu prends la colonne as tu
commencé à jouer sur la colonnade tu
défends le pion ces deux en fait la
position des nord c'est vraiment une
position d'attenté largement ce que t'as
pas t'as pas réussi à avoir le contrôle
et c'est ce que je disais avant sur le
roi maintenant ce que tu fais c'est que
tu as ton se passe un truc et les blancs
ils vont améliorer leur pièce la fois
jeu trois dates des trois mètres au mali
veut qu'un rallye ou quatre mais bon
sait pas s'il apparaît comme le 3 et
qu'est ce qui va faire maxime déjà d'un
métro tu me l'as tête retour à cette
d'un proto pointe au 4e rang et beckham
aléatoire d'amis b4 sûr qu'il prend des
cinq vallini adam d2 le retour ou pas ce
cas le curry l'emprise quand même mais
bon il ya un clouage qui semble aller sa
culture une tombe déjà
je peux si la vue on peut avoir sur la
tête de de wailly on peut voir si la
blondeur jo dan d2
ok mais même ce genre de pozo kate a
donné un pion mais tu vois qu'il ya des
claques et cinq des quinze fois je crois
pas du tout race est aussi tu peux
tenter
il ya pas b 4.4 les bateaux racette
attourath à toi est selon toi cette dame
c'est 6 16 ans car j'ai des quatre
matches hausse
c'est pour combiner les deux idées en
fait ouais mais avec le foin je crois ce
serait mieux qu'il ya d'amd cette
affaire il aurait peut-être fallu
commencer par tour un flash voyager
faire ça après pour éviter mais sur dame
ça sent ça respire pas la sérénité quand
même à weedon 17,1 peut-être un cadre en
bessin coup way avec lui car il est sain
qui reste en prise va me 8 médailles
trust iii ou questions qui fâchent et 3
je pense que les prend et tours à huit
noms qu elle reli l541 que ça me parait
méchant avec cinq dates des quatre
carrés où habite à la camerata tacle à
tafalla entre guillemets il a fait
cavalier 5-fu projet 5 dame prend pas la
banque et non d'un procès le 6 mai tu
vois qu'ils agissent dame prenait 5 dans
mesdames français apprend qu'il va lui
aussi 5 ayachi et dame prend des sags
oui vous montrez j'avais pas vu de balle
même est ce que c'est si grave bassalert
avocate qui tombe tu fais un peu la
gueule madame prend des six nations
4 qui tombe bientôt qui tombe droit si
ça peut être bon quand il achète d'am
dam e5 est donc là ce qu'il avait prévu
un temps tout reprend ses sept à tort
consistoire est le seul gagnant pour
concilier pour enquête et tourcoing
tourabi depuis cet échec on échange les
dames et en gagne la tour et sur annoncé
cette dame points à se définir
oui c'est joli ça
donc et une idée ni batterie qu'il est
très haut des trucs après ce que keshi
screenshots et gagne pas mal à cacher sa
part en effet ici je peux encore fx le
coup ouais jouer et la tension patron
c'est celle puisqu'à cavalli prend enfin
deux variantes est peut-être kaixi ce
n'était pas ce que peut-être une erreur
prise prises dix agents bien maximin
elle va regagner sa là je pense à ma
fille qui était si longtemps alors
attends je crois qu'il ya des questions
le chat mais j'ai un peu perdu
j'ai un peu perdu
bon je vois pas les gens par la question
ça va trois remontées tour des huit
tours à huit ok il veut rentrer sur la
huitième et peut-être il veut remettre
une plante 7 après le l'autre mais
surtout si tu veux faire toi maintenant
j'ai six blocs et surface lecavalier tu
en mets une tour ans et c'est tout un 17
salles installa des dix sept ans que je
t'aime
donc il est échangé il a fait état d un
avenant pour poser une question quand
même quelques mp3 gagne tour des sites
web toi tempo sur tour des huit voire
faire tourner un et il menace tour à 8
matt qu'il veut faire casser cet écueil
et c7 sais pas si c'est pas ta casquette
et cavaliers pays six gp six tours à 5
yasser tu t'en prends pions b5 c'est un
peu pénible
bon après si tu as la horde de plus
passionnés ça va peut-être changer les
belges ont clairement il peut y avoir du
v4 aussi qui traîne c'est à dire allez
bouger vous prend 1,4
ça va forcément envie de le perdre ce
pion mais je sais pas si tu as forcément
me donner la cause au cateau et un fils
a expliqué ses 7 par exemple 4,4 fou
prend 1,4 c reste un avantage non way a
pris peut faire du fou des trois tours
des quêtes pour des clubs champions aura
été bien il n'a pas le temps de faire
prise orient s'en prendre aux camélias 4
ça aurait besoin maxime qui lave à
prendre et puis maintenant ça c'est une
position facile de jouer ta [ __ ] à plus
de répèt c4 quand même mais de façon il
a plus de connexions wi au leurre que
ces 4 s'il réussit à récupérer b5 je
pense ça doit être nul
non mais c'est un bon moment encore
manqué ses trois blasons façon il a plus
de connexions qu il pourra pas tenir à
son connexion à déjeuner son enveloppe
le projet vrai pour les pulls et oui
mais c'est pour ça on s'en inquiète pas
quoi tu vois on est on est bien donc il
y avait peut-être tout reprend à 7 et
paca va y prendre d'amont souhaitent à
leur tour francis est cette enfant à cet
état qu'il prendra mais je sais pas quel
moment
mais bon c'est peu que tout le monde ait
raté un ça arrive un que tout le monde
rate ce position je suis sûr qu'elle est
nulle un nom 6 4 contre 3 aime ça les
cavaliers n'ont pas les cavaliers que
ouais mais bon tu sais que c'est pas nul
devrait pas là je go travel
non mais il va la perdre parce qu'il a
plus de temps et que ça va être dur à
tenir mais objectivement je sais pas si
elle est nue le récompense les cavaliers
ça change autant de ouais tu pousses que
jean rhein sh en quelques heures tu vois
déjà se poser à prendre
ça c'est nul c'est sûr je comprends pas
pourquoi les changes du tour alors qu'il
a plus de temps l'autre bizarre comme
choix pratique jeu ça va pas le faire si
le dixième que le deuxième de nos
messages vrai mais je sais pas on a
tellement raté les mecs dans les mecs du
chat un tellement raté ce que vous avez
ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure que
c'est c'est difficile après trente coups
plus tard de revenir dessus mais
vérifier avec l'ordinateur en fait
bêtement sur czech comme vous pouvez
vous allez ouvrir leur dit il la gagne
autant finalement ouvrir le petit truc
de variantes et puis ça vous donne ça
vous donne le résultat en réalité qu'à
une petite pause il ya une petite pause
et maxime qui est revenu à un point
blanc pose moi je vais mettre les
grandes causes je mette la pub ça relou
pendant six minutes normalement
donc moi je vous met la petite pub
alors je sais pas si vous trouvez que
c'est un beau match parce que vous en
penser les mecs
are you win donc c'est ça bloque ses
très bonnes chances de gamme quatre
contre trois avec les cavaliers ouais
non mais le fait que ce soit dur à
défendre c'est sûr mais je pense que
théoriquement c'est nul je crois mais
c'était sur la qui gagnera la connexion
n'y a pas de calais pas n'y avait pas de
mystère entre guillemets la victoire à
la connexion était était donné d'avancé
avec une mauvaise connexion défendre une
position comme ça pendant pendant des
heures c'est impossible il devait la
défendre pendant trente quarante coût
minimum est de toute façon avec une
seconde par coudonc avait aucune aucune
aucune chance de remonter et donc
c'était une victoire quasi quasi assurée
pour le joueur français donc le joueur
français qui revient à un point et qui
est plutôt qui est plutôt bien donc je
vais regarder jeter un oeil
ouais non c'est sympa d'ailleurs maxime
pour la première fois sur un stream
ça fait plaisir on a de nouveau de
nouvelles têtes et c'est top c'est
d'avoir le champion de france en bus
alors je vais mettre un peu les images
du stream officiel
il nous montre quoi top live games et il
met une question
bon comme il est imbu ya quoi adopte
dany et ses maximes encore qu'il va
adopter danny way c'est sympa ça en fait
là le pire
le petit écran qu'ils ont mis pour la
pub bref j'en ai perdu une comme ça à
rioz un quatre contre trois avec les
cavaliers avec peu de temps c'est vrai
que c'est dur à tenir mais mais là
c'était c'était infaisable
on peut avoir le grand plat devant la
pause non on l'aura on l'aura bientôt
vous l'admets mais pas sur cet événement
royer artemiev qui va qui va jouer qui
va jouer aussi
le speech s il ya elina danielian qui va
jouer demain demain c'est à 16h aussi de
mémoire et ce sera le match nepomniachi
danielian donc on va voir si danielian
on peut marquer plus de deux ou trois
points dans le match ce sera un peu
l'intérêt de voir à quel point
quel score on va avoir donc ce sera cool
dingli rennes qui joue aussi cette année
ça va être intéressant de voir ce que
donne le joueur chinois même si joueur
habile à jouer il a joué cette nuit du
coup contre contre-champ clan effet pas
regarder le résultat mais il doit déjà
avant le résultat je vais essayer de
vous chopez ça je vais essayer de vous
choper le résultat
wen et paul va être il va être gros gros
favoris attendant je vais essayer de
vous dire ce qui s'est passé dans le
match il ya vlad d'oberhof qui s'est
qualifié donc ce sera un match aussi
intéressant puisqu'on sera à fond contre
lui ce sera marrant je sais plus
exactement quand les dates gens qui
gênent christophe duda donc encore un no
make et je suis en train d'essayer de
chercher je suis en train d'essayer de
chercher de trouver le le résultat du
match d'hier je suis réussir à trouver
du mr x ou y à sa s ur le jazz comme
officiel mais pour une raison x ou y ça
me donne tous les deux chaises comme du
monde sauf le vrai jazz comme alors une
pièce comme officiel ils sont très
heureux du match à présent alors ça on
s'en fiche sans fils sans s'en fichent
faut que le scroll un peu
[Musique]
sedighi rennes qui a gagné 19 à 12 ça
c'est prévisible après 1
donc ouais non il y aura il y aura
d'autres of eye là il va pas faire long
feu de façon il va perdre au premier
tour
soyons clairs soyons clairs soyons
honnêtes avec d'oberhof il passe pas un
tour les tontons il passe même pas un
demi tour
donc il y aura ma mais aussi au delà de
broc contre la grotte des forêts gras
retrouve cette partie elle est allée
quelque part sur la chaîne et que je la
mette donc je checke tout se passe bien
de partout
donc donc on regarde un cheveu wandering
de pesage von teese strike the most
addictives ou et tout seul ce puzzle ça
me prouve leur tactique serait scellé
petite pub pour puzzle roche pas mal à
quelle heure commence la prochaine
partie la prochaine partie elle débute
dans donc dans deux minutes peut-être
très rapidement en tout cas de preuve tu
passe pas un seul tour tu fais demi tour
quand tu pars au quart de tour
non mais d'oberhof droit qu'il va faire
marche arrière il va comprendre qu'il
fallait pas se qualifier mais bon après
de brefs on comprend pas trop parce que
d'un autre côté enfin j'arrive a quand
même gagné un title tuesday quoi donc
j'ai envie de dire on ne sait pas le
bail avec de brefs et entier maxime qui
va qui va revenir
tu vas nous rejoindre maxime était de
retour oui talent et de chercher un
petit verdot
rien qu'a fait un café tu souffles à une
machine à café tu fais du nespresso qui
fait quoi si tu as un petit expresso l
espresso est surchauffée du nespresso
du coup quand tu viens à karine je vais
t'apprendre affaires à faire leurs
machines la petite cafetière italienne a
commencé mais je crois que c'est comment
vas tu as une petite tu vois pas à quoi
ça ressemble les titres cafetière
italienne
si tu me montres une peut-être ça se met
sur une plaque sur les plaques sur les
plaques sur les plaques de cuisine est
en fait tu met de l'eau dessous tu mets
le caf au milieu et du coup le café
quand quand l'ol va chauffer il va
passer à travers
ah oui d'accord oui la trilogie lieux et
sites amateurs de café c'est le top ok
bâtiment juste enfreint le temps frais
gt gt bien vers j'avais acheté du super
café quand vlad était venu pour
commenter le le grand prix et il me dit
wen en fait j'ai arrêté le café et du
coup maintenant il fait du thé matcha
ils voient que ce à quoi je partais pas
le match à c'est un peu spécial c'est de
la poudre verte
tu mets un peu d'eau dedans et tu
rajoutes lui mais du lait d'avoine
dedans c'est vrai un peu spécial mais il
en boit il envoie quatre par jour quoi
mais bon ça c'est là d'un il te dis oui
très très bon pour la santé
excellent ya que lui qui dit ça à quoi
mais bon après c'est intéressant
vlada ses propres ses propres théories
sur la santé bon il faut savoir un truc
très sain d'après vlad c'est de manger
au fast-food asiatiques bah je suis un
grand fan du parce que asiatiques
ouais bah c'est pas très stable on
mélange la dite jeudi très sincère qu'en
fait il va vraiment mon show face aux
asiatiques quand tu vois quand il est
dans le dur et dit bon je suis obligé de
manger sain aujourd'hui c'est fou mais
des grands fans et face aux asiatiques
aussi j'adore c'est peut-être le fou en
commun le seul et y en a pas mal autour
de chez toi des bons ou et si on a un
très bon c'est un coréen va être sympa
ça très bon très bon très bon et donc
qui va très souvent tu vois si souvent
parce que je me fais ma bouffe ou quand
même moins cher c'est plus sympa mais
bon quand tu as l'occasion vin est par
contre quand je fais manger en ville je
suis là quand tu t'es trop pourri la
santé à manger des crudités des légumes
à chez toi tu te dis oui bon enfin il
faut enfin que je récupère bien tu vas
prendre des nems voilà tu manges de truc
léger quoi
alors c'est tron a du coup à cannes on a
vraiment un très bon un très bon face
aux asiatiques aussi pour la peine pas
loin de la gare mais pas les buffets à
volonté
non je plains volonté normand c'est pas
un buffet à volonté
très bonne qualité avec frappe du cou il
en avait marre quoi parce que je sais
pas pour une raison x ou y ont à un
délire c2c de faire ce que dit vladan
fête et de prendre ce qu'ils racontent
au premier degré et de se faire un petit
délire donc je sais pas quand on est
revenus du marché on était allé prendre
le petit déjeuner ensemble
on revient il était 12h15 et on passe
devant le fast-food asiatiques
on n'avait pas du tout fan tu vois
parfois mais on s'est senti obligé femme
a dit oui on est quand même je pense
obligé de de manger sain pour pour avoir
plein de le plein de vitamines donc on
va quand même manger là et le jour
d'après du coup on allait manger dans un
resto thaï qui est vraiment très bon
pour la peine à côté de chez moi bien au
dessus du faso d'asiatiques bien
évidemment mais on était très mécontent
on a eu une très mauvaise qualité
c'est horrible ' pour pour rester dans
le délire là tu as daniel rennes jld qui
fait n'importe quoi qui raconte
voilà qui raconte sa life et ça va
repartir avec du 3 + 1 une heure donc il
va y avoir à peu près autant de parties
ok et oui qui a mis ses lunettes
donc là on comprend pas c'est à dire que
peut-être qu'il voit mal mais qui se met
à faire un jeu comprend pas en fait
l'intérêt des lunettes la fête soit les
fans c'est peut-être aller mieux
lunettes lumière bleue on peut pas avoir
mal au crâne
tu penses je sais pas chez lui comme
hubble mais juste c'est bizarre j'en
aurai jamais mis de lunettes de sa vie
elle a tout d'un coup il se dit oui en
fait c'était ça le problème je vois très
mal je vois flou depuis des années j'ai
enfin trouvé la solution quazar par là
non ouais ça repart on va repartir on va
repartir sur les échecs tu as ta daniel
à tendance du coup on voit du règne chez
l'on voit daniel partout en fait attend
faut que je dégage des mirages marseille
dernière et disparus
et donc c'est une sicilienne avec foulée
cinq échecs qui a validé cette sais pas
si c'est ce que tu fous toi aussi avec
les noirs ça dépend ça m'arrive je
commence plutôt marquée des catéchismes
pas par des six d'accord donc tu te
retrouves avec toutes les variantes du
match
karl scène caruana l'imaginent chez
jésus les préparer d'ailleurs j'ai une
partie que tu as dû l'avoir city
commentait contre cornette oui c'était
c'était caruana kursaal way était un peu
moins bien en j'étais moins bien ouais
je il avait fait le truc avec bk retrait
tout et il a amélioré l'améliorer truc
ça m'étonne pas de mathieu et quand tu
comptes mathieu cornette du coup t'es
sur qui va te sortir qu'il faut sortir
de l'ouverture non mathieu c'est son
gros point fort la théorie donc j'avais
j'avais pas mal travaillé l'arceau pour
ce tournoi
et voilà il a travaillé plus que moi
faut croire
j'ai envie de te dire c'est pas étonnant
vu les prépas de mathieu mois il
m'impressionne 1 il est vraiment
incroyable non match mais il a été super
idée non c'est vraiment un poids lourd
de la théorie française clairement non
mais au delà de ça c'est un très bon
joueur le championnat de france il a
fait des très bonnes parties il n'a pas
été récompensé mais clairement il a fait
que des bottes porcien là bizarrement si
tu regardes les parties si tu regardes
les éval
c'est peut-être lui qui aurait dû être
contre toi en finale voire même gagné
salins après bon sa chaussure sur une
partie entière oui oui oui bien sûr mais
il avait il a eu du pot il emménage
faidherbe fait larsen même où c'est le
même le même casse et qui a fait leur a
fait des très bonnes parties l'a jamais
été moins bien je pense de tout le
tournoi et au final il termine à 4 4 et
demi oui oui là il a pas il n'a pas fini
de super bien c'est vrai il a fini avec
50% avec -1 50% ya quelques années fait
que des nuls et gozzo et segodo et qui a
perdu la dernière contre toi justement
et du coup qui est pas forcément
qualifié pour l'année prochaine mais ça
devrait passer aux lots à l'époque oui
oui drôle ça passe par des lots bien
avec je sais même pas qui a été
requalifiée en avant tout cas senna
tommaso faut qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils
reprennent des points new way maso qui
pourrait qui pourrait pas jouer l'année
prochaine mais maso qui est un peu en
perte de vitesse depuis depuis depuis
quelques mois à tirana il avait fait un
gros orage dans un moment on ne mène pas
au sens un très bon jour reçu gt26
rentes pendant pendant un petit moment
le vespa mais j'ai l'impression que
c'est tellement dur de tenir ce vélo oui
oui non si ses supérieurs à ce que
mathieu aussi il était ya pas si
longtemps il était il était au dessus de
26 et puis tout d'un coup en fait genre
tu fait deux trois tournois
enfin même pas mauvais tu fais juste de
trois tournois moyens et tu coules quoi
laisser comme fraises fresques et 26 et
je vais le tournant à 26 ans c'est un
truc qui l'a jamais été 26 fois de sa
vie quote oui cfoot a plutôt
l'impression de devoir l'avoir à 26,70
c'est encore à 26 ans était pas
forcément compagne ils étaient sept ans
et il a fêté longtemps tue de 27 oui oui
non il a passé il a passé très longtemps
tue de 27
non mais fraisse à 26 ans était pas un
cadeau alors maxime a gagné l'italie
c'est peut-être pas si simple non
barilla je vais toucher 5
jouer ce système ça va calmer
bon il peut égaliser en écoute et il
peut il peut lui remettre ça réussit il
se sera pris 1 5 0 il peut lui en mettre
4 0 alors on se pose la question parce
qu'on est et on l'a on a vu cette
question et cette petite discussion tout
début de ce trimestre ce que tu pense
pouvoir atteindre les 2700 et si oui
d'ici combien de temps c'est une
question de cyril 85,74 je pense
atteindre les 2700 j'espère pouvoir les
autres en un jour ni ma vie quand même
et d'ici combien de temps j'en ai
absolument clean et parce qu'en fait
tous ceux de ma catégorie d'âge dont
j'avais j'avais l'habitude de les jouer
par exemple vie dit cette eau rahman et
compagnie j'avais à peu près leur niveau
dans la catégorie d'âge et ils sont tous
passés 27 vit-il et 27 37 il est
vraiment bon et renfort et pourtant à
l'époque dans la même catégorie d'âge il
n'était pas spécialement beaucoup plus
fort que moi le problème est lié donc
j'espère en me basant sur des joueurs
comme ça que je vais attendre les
vingt-sept un jour mais je pouvais pas
donner donner une date
et déjà se paie une espérance entre
guillemets j'espère me maintenir à 26 50
je regarde la néo pro de l'année depuis
devant de maintenir entre 26 51 26 95
et après essayer de faire un gros rush
et voilà mais j'imagine que tu espères
être devenir un joueur
2007 à long terme sert pas être 2007
écoulé quoi sur j'équipe c'est d'avoir
2007 et de les maintenir
j'imagine aussi si c'est pas de tabou
bien sûr que c'est financièrement c'est
aussi même assez intéressant de passer
au dessus de 1700 non je crois que tu as
online dans un autre c'est possible du
coup je connais pas trop secondes mais
c'est possible
a mon avis oui j'ai cette impression que
tu rentres quand même dans une catégorie
un peu plus sélect où tu es si on
commence à te proposer des tournois
affirmé un peu plus intéressant pas
besoin de tout boeuf qui a passé la
démission récemment il est il ya
plusieurs des tournois comme le grand
prix et compagnie oui tu peux tu peux tu
peux jouer un grand thiès pour paris par
exemple tu peux avoir la chance de jouer
un tournoi comme ça il imagine tu faire
un très bon score à ce tournoi après ça
ça s'enchaîne boule de neige est un peu
un peu comme un homme a réussi à faire
douter
ouais par exemple outaouais non mais
deux d'entre eux parient ferroudja
bientôt ça sera ce sera lui dans les
tournois comme ça wifi roja après c'est
encore une autre c'est encore une autre
dimension très jeune je veux dire par là
oui voilà c'est ça parce que pour
l'instant je trouve tout à plus fort que
cheyrou déjà vu clairement clairement
méfieront déjà si tu mets en larmes
chirac il a hélas que c'est fou c'est
vous les rues de là c'est vraiment fou
alors cette position alors je comprends
pas pourquoi la page du c4 parce qu'on
parlait mais
ce qui va vraiment réussir à progresser
avec les blancs ah oui il a pris le
parti d'attendre mais là il va alors
avoir la connexion à voir la connexion
ivan flag et ouverture f projet
catherine c'est le plan classique à et
joue pas avec jacob zuma le flag bas des
échanges et maintenant il ya le roi qui
va baisser a eu lieu si cela aussi c6 c7
et le thème classique tour d2 prendre le
pion et votre maxime nationale qui va
égaliser à la voile à des cubes bouge le
fouille à tour des huit c8 et c'est fini
alors ça fait 5 partout et je pense que
c'est là qu'il faut vraiment appuyé sur
l'accélérateur maintenant maxime je
pense est important de pas se relâcher
ah voilà ça change non on va commencer
mais je sais possible que why i et
préparer des ouvertures pour cadence en
serait pas la première fois qu'on voit
ça dans un pièce je vais pas débile
c'est pas évident parce qu'ils jouaient
que h3 dont la cadence d'avant et
maintenant ils commencent à changer
donc là c'est un peu empoisonné voilà
c'est une langue qui est beaucoup plus
tactique beaucoup plus chaude bonne
quand à moins de temps c'est d'un autre
côté ce que je vois ça avec maxime c'est
une bonne idée je suis patient il
connaît il connaît bien ambitieux fiq
avait le chipeau des pulls ou alors
connexion non là il connaît ouais ou
alors connexion mais je pense juste
qu'il connaît plus alors roger intérêts
qui j'ai pas vu le début oui mené 5-0
alors qu'il menait 5 1 il y avait 1 0
pour maxime et il a enchaîné une femme
peut-être une victoire un nul et cinq et
quatre victoires
donc il a enchaîné il lui a mis un petit
5 0 est la maxime qui vient de répondre
par un petit 4 0 un livre déchets qui
m'a marqué le jet ski le mali le dg way
le manuel des finales tu recommandes
avait clairement c'est peut-être un peu
compliqué que je sais pas qu'est le quel
niveau tu as gros chatons marron mai
mais c'est un très bon livre toi tu l'as
lu kant avait quel niveau ce livre j'ai
commencé je le lis encore parce que tu
es obligé de le relire plusieurs fois
pour te re te rappeler tout mais j'ai
commencé à le lire je devais avoir 22400
je crois qu'un joueur comme reach ou que
le lit une fois par an wen dans le ciel
minimum j'ai un élève et du coup ça me
permet de le jouer
il regarde ce livre très intéressant
en fait je tue le foot in en même temps
il fut quand un élève ça te force à bien
le comprendre toi-même aussi mais après
les vifs sur les meilleures parties de
kasparov ce que kasparov c'est quand
même notre dieu à tous
il a il a encore des beaux restes c'est
tata regarde un petit peu hier soir ou
pas leurs yeux très très rapidement même
j'ai juste regardé la vidéo de naka qui
était encore désagréable quand il a
perdu contre lorient ouais mais c'est
marrant parce qu'ils étaient mieux donc
trois des quatre parties contre caruana
bon après il réussit pas à finir parce
que parce que parce qu'il se prend d
cheapos parce qu'il a plu le 8 de joie
mais ouais mais sinon il dominait encore
vraiment un mec à ce moment c'est vrai
pour moi c'est vraiment le meilleur
joueur est encore prématuré le débat de
huit à neuf chaînes de machin de
l'époque de bobby fischer aussi de
morphine fin mai mais c'est vrai que
kasparov s'est quand même passé celui
qui m'a le plus marqué en ligue 1 puis
l'avait ce style universel tu le vois
encore aujourd'hui même si c'était un
gros joueur d'attaqué tout il savait
tout faire quoi non mais c'est un très
très bon et aussi il a eu la chance j'en
discutais avec vlad et il faisait qu'une
des grandes chances de garris d'avoir eu
énormément de particules karpov
ouais bon coup tu vois karpov ça
m'impressionne pas ouais mais il a quand
même un oui il est pas impressionnant a
un style qui est moins impressionnant il
a ainsi pu positionner le plus technique
sais pas ouais mais de niveau du style
moins impressionnant mais quand tu
penses à sa carrière et ce qu'il a fait
c'est quand même un monstre aussi s'il
n'y avait pas eu kasparov qui serait
resté au top pendant pendant 20 30 ans
quoi
imaginez enfin ces niveaux de ouf quand
il est revenu tu vas y perd les matches
du championnat du monde il revient il re
bas tout le monde feint c'est l'invasion
non évidemment c'est faux on parle de
gens croyaient wind ans après on accepte
le fait c'est le cac40 fait est fait
complètement de l'ombre à karpov qui
fait que ça montre à quel point kasparov
serbe a laissé ça qu'il faut un job
exactement c'est exactement là que je
voulais en venir c'est que en réalité
car poissy a pas kasparov ce serait face
ce serait une légende totale du jeu est
en fait ces fins os et kasparov il est
tellement légendaire en fait mais en
fait même ce qui nous oppose le choc
connaissent kasparov sur audika karpov
qui vont car une fois le net quand même
ils vivront ils parce que ça ressemble à
kasparov mes sarcasmes et kasparov tu
avais aussi le le charisme
les gens connaissent fischer les castors
même carson en dehors des échecs
j'aime bien les gens ils connaissent pas
là ils connaissent pas ne connaissent
pas comment quand on demande c'est qu'il
champion du monde maintenant tu dit carl
ça ne l'est mais qui sont là en mode
sais qui tu vas genre même mon père qui
jouait pas mal à l'époque il est
ils étaient mille huit cent cinquante
mille neuf cent mais tu vois dans les
années début des fin des années 90 début
des années 2000 tu as donc c'est donc
vraiment pas mal tu vois c'est un bon
joueur et je vois que carl scène il
connaît pas ce qui me connais tu vois
mais je pense si jouer comme ça mais ils
connaîtraient de long il m'a même
demandé à tiens c'est encore 45 champion
du monde tu essayes même pas qu'ils
aient battu caruana un fou c'est alors
que bon il a le livre mais 60 meilleures
parties de karpov sur sa table de chevet
encore aujourd'hui tu vois
et du coup c'est vrai que tu as raison
dans le sens où karpov et kasparov c'est
vrai ces derniers jours a vraiment connu
tu as un truc de trois des huit russe
est alors agent aurait plus d'un mois
six mois d ingrid suspense the game les
rois c7 ouais ok si ce 7e tour 8
l'ajustant william hague manche a gagné
mais fou prend des cinq au prochain nous
aurons huit ou maghrébine tu es fou j'ai
cinq fautes 3 mais il prend son temps
maintenant maximin mais quand même
minute
oui mais j'ai quand il est gagnante il
reprend 2,3
il te re joue pas ce week end c'est
gagner là bas ça va c'est ça il ya mis 5
0 ont un avantage on nous dit que les
noms du connu du grand public sont
souvent associés à des phénomènes
sociaux et historiques aussi way russie
messieurs c'est certain donc il ya plus
un et il nous reste combien de temps
trois minutes sur important de regarder
il reste 45 minutes donc on au début du
match de 3 minutes et maxime qui a déjà
pris les devants et il semble aussi
qu'ils soient favoris pour pour les
bullet maxime en cas de belle en cas de
connexion
la connexion de huy et pape semble pas
pas en béton armé donc tu en as bien
fait de pas s'inquiéter
on a bien fait de pas s'inquiéter
j'ai pas vraiment que le match il a
tourné sur les deux parties là où maxime
a gagné en souffrent un peu je dirais il
eu des bonnes positions il a un peu il a
gagné un peu à l'arraché on santé qui
soufflait vraiment quand ils emportaient
salariaux de confiance il domine
il joue plus vite encore je sais pas si
c'est la connexion aux pommes
et il joue beaucoup plus près de façon à
mon avis a pas que de la connexion là
parce qu'ils vont plus vite que dans
tout l'est dans tous les tournois en
réel dans tous les grands de chaises
sourds de partout il est toujours mieux
autant il est juste plus fort c'est tout
un faux pas faux pas qui rageaient les
chinois faudra qu'ils envoient dingli
rennes la prochaine fois histoire
histoire d'avoir un peu un match
il saura quelque chose d'intéressant
donc est-ce que puisque tourbe et un
singe avait demandé six tours ben tu
pensais que ça défendez le plus inquiets
30 b2 prendre ces deux effets retour en
france et 6 mais ça se dirige vers une
autre position
est-ce que tout reprend ses six
cavaliers aux 7es faut prononcer si ça
peut être une idée ça peut être une idée
mais là les choses sont donc fouet f5
qui fait quoi ils contrôlent la case b1
mais là il peut gagner un truc non
siglés s'apprécie de 4 kg le gras sur je
prends un il veut faire pions prend f5
il attaquera le cavalier le fou et je te
dirai oui oui maxime qui a l'air d'être
hyper confiant là bas je crois qu'il je
crois que oui il a eu la tête dans le
sac
il ajoute que l'on peut encore fait ce
nom je pense qu'il a la tête dans
l'ouest l'est là il est mal
non là il est dans le dur là là il est
dans le dur oui bon il fait toujours la
même tête mais en fait il sait qu on
sait qu'il est dans le dur
dallas il n'a jamais vraiment confirmé
c'était le plus jeune joueur à 2700 et
finalement il fait des études en
maintenant maintenant c'est ce que les
gens disent mais j'ai envie de dire il a
fait pschitt qua non mais vraiment pas
je vais au bout d'un moment je comprends
pas le délire de dire oui je fais enfin
je fais des études ok bon il fait des
études probablement mai
en face tu pouvais être champion du
monde est ce que tu fais des études
bhatia la chine assez compliqué sur lui
faire des études sur l'avs ai dit de
continuer à jouer aux échecs elle
continue à la hausse échec je sais pas
comment ça se passe là bas et je sais
que tu fais plus ou moins secondes
oui oui d'entraîneur c'est très
certainement mais mais d'un autre côté
est ce qu'ils te disent d'aller faire
des études tu peux être champion du
monde par une fois pas très belle jeu
cet après après peut-être qu'ils veulent
pas trop de rivalités entre joueurs
chinois parce qu'il est déjà digne et
rennes et du yang toiture gear un
meilleur potentiel que c'est quand même
spécial garder je sais pas prêcher pas
qui sait qu'il veut raconter ça avec
band qui allait complètement dans ton
sens et qui me disait que en chine faire
des études
abbas était en quête du rire jaune que
faire des études c'était vraiment
important pour eux ah oui
donc va savoir mais pour moi ça me
paraît enfin pour nous occidentaux ça
paraît tellement étrangement à berlin à
notre style de vie sains
c'est le plus dur clairement 20 août
imagine tu étais 20e mondial dans ton
dans ton domaine à 20 ans par être
quasiment jamais en réalité il ya joué
il ya genre pas de cas de figure où tu
arrêtes et je suis d'accord c'est fou
quoi eux ils sont là ou en mode non
sérieux n'était pas assez fort le
terrain tu es un peu mauvais en fait
pour toi c'est pas fait pour toi les
échecs fait des études ce sera mieux
tête après là et il a pas d'art d'avoir
arrêté complètement mais en ont ils à
part été complètement mehiaoui lifan
aussi qui est parti faire des études
ouais oui bon tu n'es que championne du
monde mais je crois que l justement elle
s'était bien ni émancipé du dictateur
chinois et je crois que c'est elle je
son plein gré qu'on avait marre un
viaduc lycée du oui je me barre qu une
arme et c'est avec l'histoire de deux
tournois du circuit féminin et compagnie
elle était un peu oui
elle n'aime pas trop la vie dit oui les
appariements les appariements de
gibraltar à n'avait pas aimé du tout
quant à l'effet forfait je joue trop 2
si j'arrête là les mêmes même pas fait
pour tuer des jouets f3 de detroit 3 +
genre ouais elle avait perdu
elle avait eu un il avait une
un problème pas une suspension ou une
amende quelque chose comme ça je crois
oui je crois qu'il y avait un problème
je sais pas si c'est aller jusqu'au bout
mais mais savait pas vraiment plu à
l'organisation elle étudia cambridge
quand on lui dit d'ailleurs regretté
rang et donc maxime qui a encore gagné
et ça fait maintenant plus deux annoncés
c'est vraiment un gros écart 1 commence
à se former parce que il est sur une
série de 6 à 0
là il a peut-être missclick non ouais
c'est possible encore que il peut jouer
à carreaux cân tho trop tôt de profonds
oui mais non mais bien sûr ce soir plus
il en être capable après ce pas trop son
style mais tu voyais mal r2 de connaître
on ne décrit dans le chatt mpl qui
s'ennuient
c'est vrai que il m'a l'air d'être
facile quoi dès qu'il a décidé vraiment
de de passer la surmultipliée là oui il
peut pas résister 1 il est vraiment il
est vraiment mal est ce qui s'est passé
pour le temps qu'ils en perdent quatre
de suite bah écoute il semblait il
semble être dans le dur un vraiment vous
voyez qui semblait mais qu'il semblait
marcher sur l'eau et maxime maxime qui
était clairement derrière et puis tout
d'un coup ça s'est retourné
mais c'est un peu tu suis un peu le
tennis ou pas de loin ça arrive des
matches comme ça où tu as un mec fort là
il ya deux trois jours il y avait
medvedev contre copper je pense ouais ou
s'il te siffler c'est sur le tour
d'après ben est en fait il est mené 1
set 0 l'autre mène 3 1 je crois donc la
vie dit tu te dis ouais c'est chaud et
puis les plus ou moins dominé puis
revient à 3-2 et puis
il break il vrai que le mec en faisant
une balle let et en ayant un peu de
enfin je voulais vraiment de la réussite
clairement et du moment où il a breaké
revenir à 3-3 c'était cavalier seul il a
dû gagner le set 6-4 6-2 la est ok il ya
eu tie break dans le dernier mais il a
vraiment pris le dessus
georges jusqu'à ce moment du match en
fait avait l'impression que l'autre il
était au-dessus quoi et tout d'un coup
il ya un petit truc positif qui arrivait
pour lui et c'était fini c'était le
rouleau compresseur qui était en route
là c'est un peu pareil avec maxime tu as
l'impression qu'il était dans le dur il
en a gagné deux un peu à l'arraché même
s'il était bien et puis c'était oui
c'est comme si oui ça ça je faisais
lâcher quoi donc et au visuel fatigué il
est tard chez lui jusqu'à l'arrivée en
chine si vous pouvez nous dire mais
c'est vrai qu'il est peut-être une heure
du matin 6 heures de bus fin à minuit
du coup c'est vrai que ça peut aussi
jouer 5 ça peut aussi jouer toi je sais
pas tu joues bien le soir où je suis pas
trop du soir je suis plus du matin tu
travailles tu te lèves à quelle heure le
matin ce n'est pas indiscret très tôt
sept heures entre 7h et sérieux je sais
pas pourquoi je me serais dit l' inverse
j'arrive pas à me lever tard assez fou
une fois je suis réveillé je peux pas
moins dans l'air sérieux c'est fou et du
coup tu as ta routine c'est quoi le
matin tu t'entraînes un peu tu prends le
petit déj tube lendemain je glandouille
d'aujourd'hui tu glandouille je fais des
chefs de musique donc des tombes tu fais
de la musique
ouais tu composes normalement je joue tu
joue de la musique tu veux quel
instrument du piano marrant ça tue en
apprend des choses est belle tu avais
pas du tout joué du piano était un
tintin les bulletins ce qu'il fait
depuis huit ans donc tu te tues tu as et
devant ton piano et tu étais pillages je
te laisse emporter tel s'emporter
emporté par mozart non sérieux sérieux
ouais ça des fous
là j'apprends j'apprends du jean jacques
goldman
j'apprends peu de tout c'est marrant ça
assis dessus ou là je suis une grosse
info là quand même
mais tu vois je te voyais pas jouer du
piano après enfin ccbbo coiffe un total
respect mais je sais pas pourquoi je te
voyais pas jouer du piano enfin après
après tu voyais peut-être pas écouté
dérape contenders le matin pour me
détendre
tu vois ce genre ont chacun ses hobbies
un peu space quoi moi j'aime bien j'aime
bien j'aime bien les clashs de rap donc
du coup a dévoilé les classes de musique
classique oui c'est pas le même délire
mais mes gros respect pour la musique
classique c'est ça c'est un truc où à
chaque fois je me dis faudrait que je
m'y intéresse parce que c'est un peu la
honte d'écouté que du rap et j'écoute de
la vraie musique un jour et je n'arrive
pas vraiment à comprendre tu vois ce que
je veux tu que je sens que c'est bien en
fait
mais j'ai pas la sensibilité du truc
mais c'est par manque de culture c'est
pas parce qu'il ya plusieurs styles je
suis sûr que tu trouves tu trouves ton
bonheur ample même écoute si tu peux me
conseillez après le stream des choses à
écouter alors c'est pas vraiment de la
musique classique mais la musique de
film c'est évident que tu aimes andy
murray à tort ou à raison je connais pas
at il connaît pas en dealer qui connaît
pas les bo des films mais je ne connais
un tas non vraiment vraiment pas en bas
je te conseille à un artiste cbi de vigo
inaudi je suis un grand fan
ok ok je vais écouter ça vraiment je
fais le réécouter no fake je vais
écouter et non moi tu parles de wojtek
tu me parles de gens comme ça je connais
les mérites de bicolline adige tard
entendu mais tu es tu connais ma méthode
joe cole oui bah si c'est connu si la
face à la musique dans tout changer le
compositeur ouais nan mais j'ai
forcément entendu ces chants
après je connais un peu la mule la
musique de la ligue des champions là tu
vois là on est bien je encore une
victoire
bon bah c'est un massacre en fait un ce
match j'ai envie d'y aller même quinze
ans de suivre en vue j'ai envie de te
dire oui enfin à quoi on va pas dit plus
tôt non mais c'est un punching ball
c'est quoi en fait le délire il il est
venu
il est venu se faire claquer en fait
qu'on va c'est pas le nom mais je vais
au bout d'un moment abandonne qu'enfin
par toi c'est ça de la rue millions là
est intéressante d'ailleurs il va
envoyer chez il a battu encore une
compatriote de wailly elle jouait john
savage et 4 là ça va faire mal
allez allez allez on voit on voit il
réfléchit me va le faire si le faible
olala chez lui à le faire au prochain
faire très attention aux pieds qui peut
arriver car non non
comment il nous a habitué à mieux maxime
là je suis très déçu
maintenant c'est très décevant là mais
je crois que il n'est pas encore
complètement relâché enfin nice il a
pris le dessus etc
mais les chances il a compris qu'il fait
le buzz dans rapporte le plus que propre
à gauche ouais non il veut où il veut
pas risquer il veut pas laisser revenir
dans le match
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas stupide de jeu
est plutôt calme que oui je suis très
bien dans le plus chiant compliqué donc
il a quoi il a plus d'activité il est
bien placé dans mais il est très très
bien la balle et des mieux être
également un peu oui forcément en fait
ils allaient tour ils allaient tous
redoublé sur des quêtes peut-être faire
f34 non je crois il a peut-être mort de
sousse et 5 or mais peu fou enfin bien
entouré sa course les quatre japonais
pour ses gâteaux
as-tu layada mérite encore mes tours
c'est cette tu vois ça comme ça commence
à faire mal en europe cette foulée cinq
carrières les réserves attention pas
fait refouler 5 direct par contre pas se
rendre l'âme projet de maths
donc oui qu'est-ce qu'un clic et c'est
quoi son projet en fait ce qu'il veut
faire
maxime qui se reconcentre à la famille à
qui aimait son nom sur dame prend tout
reprend tout reprendre à me prendre en b
5 et l'adjonction de quoi de la table et
sur assist qui est stocké prend 1,6 mais
bon c'est pas encore un avantage décisif
mais ça commence à se construire un an
sans doute également mais je pense qu'il
ya rien il va faire tour c8 et il va
tout colmater tout cas maxime qui a
l'air concentré il cherche quelque chose
là alors garé fait des petites des
petits tête j'allais petite moue qui
grimace
ça ne marche pas ce que je calcule mais
oui du coup s'il peut pas empêcher tour
ses huit tours des huit au prochain tour
c'est un vieux jeu
je sais un peu étonnés comme mesdames
mais ce que j'aime pas trop stich va
jusqu'au bout mouche
ouais mais attend sur bouffe il veut
peut-être vous fait la gauche et de
choix à 5 des quatre cavaliers ou 17 des
cas d'échec la quitte et fou c'est
peut-être choisi ce nom fief prend des
50 ans et investissent
ouais c'est pas d'égal que son talent
oratoire ce qui se passe donc les dames
f4 prises ces huit prix ces huit prises
ici l'a fait assister il s'essaie
tébessa et donc il a vu différemment et
à 4 mais a il ya pas le capitaine non
foisonnent
[Musique]
genre un kung fu des bustes foulée 8
faut cinq noms cavaliers sept fous d ici
j'aime pas trop non plus mais bon si ça
tient ça tient c'est maxime qui m'a
appris ça mais il est très important si
ça marche ça marche
en tout cas on est parti pour ça faut 5
et 17 food et ici ça va être joué je
pense il peut être dans le dur il peut
être dans le cinq
un sort mieux et non simplifie tel quel
et provincial après oui il arrête
l'hémorragie 1 à 5 à 5 6 milliards et
hémorragies studio pour lui de faire une
nulle et peut-être repartir de plus
belle après il va faire ses huit f3 il
va monter le roi objectivement fosep
j'aurais même parfois les gens seraient
mieux donc faux ça tu vois quoi aussi
dessous des 4 et sur fouquet 4 après ça
doit aller quand même pour les sur
l'épaule alors ça va sûrement même
l'europe donc c'est peut-être même les
noirs en réalité qui sont mieux
d'ailleurs je le pion dépassé
et bon maxime qui va au pire tu fais 5 g
5 laissé jusqu'à ta chambre tu as
toujours la paire sujets sains non les
noirs isme non ils sont pas mieux non
dubaï j'ai pensé avec la structure mais
en réalité non on nous dit que les noirs
ont que 20 secondes
ouais c'est vrai maxime qui tente
quelque chose là non elle a expliqué que
j'échoue bécotte c'est bizarre on sent
qu'il a une idée derrière la tête mais
je vois pas laquelle je pense que je
vais tout décote ça commence à devenir
encore chaud pour willy temps il va
pousser il va tenter g5 qui va faire
quoi il peut faire flamber quatre fous d
ici sous ses sept
bon c'est pas le mener à grand chose en
réalité il peut pas percé quoi je pense
pas qu'ils le jouent à la connexion non
ils vont faire nul ou bon ils gardent
ils gardent trois points d'avancé il
reste 26 minutes dans la cadence pour le
moment le match
le match qui se passe vraiment bien on
va voir s'il y arrive six voiliers
réussi à réagir quand même si il en
gagnait 2,3 d'affilée il pourrait
revenir dans le match bien évidemment
donc il va falloir quand même serré le
jeu pour pour maxime est pas et pas
retomber dans ses travers du début de
match donc qu'elles sont raconte dans le
tchad dans le chat ça parle de musique
un monde ici de parler musique
les autres raisons et les voisins se
plaignent pas trop que du piano du coup
non parce que j'ai un piano électrique
je fais ces leçons et du coup devient
électrique c'est pas un peu le niveau
zéro du piano est trop dit non parce que
ça 1 deux qualités gamme pas donné c'est
pas c'est pas de l'icco plus qua non
c'était pas le pied de bavière c'est un
beau piano
non c'est un yamaha a tant aimée c'est
incroyable mais tout ça je sais leur
théorie carrosse qui joue à une vitesse
et en fait il a dû se tromper tout à la
ruine variante parce qu'il est reparti
dans le tarn franges et 5 mai il a pris
en il a fait dame c4 avant donc tout à
l'heure il avait dû se entre clubs non
classés à leur bord sud autorise qu'est
le 5 quai des syndicats peut-être
cavalli à 6,6 du coup pour couvrir la
case aussi c'est couvrir des cinq pays
ces cinq québécois piles aa
il nous faut c'est trois des huit qui a
huit fougier 5 qui et b6 là ça va être
suffisant ce qui je l ai vitesse
15 morts y avoir foule tour 8 on va
avoir un c'est une belle partie ouais
j'aime mais l'énorme talent quatre feux
follets 6h aussi ses quatre pieds tu
peux faire tout bruit très peut-être sur
food et trois du coup cavaliers prend
1,4
parce que choquer les français victor
accueille ces trois qui prend bien ou
pas ou cavale et j'ai trois quais pour
un achat peut-être mieux d'aller prendre
cette tour là au moins quand il va te
reprend non tu seras obligé de et sur
roc taf ou trois cavaliers f2 oui mais
c'est un moindre mal
il est courageux 1 mais après ce qu'avec
les noirs on a vraiment quelque chose
ici qui est tu veux faire tout rêve cad
j'imagine way to have fun
roger trois tours gk3 f2 juste perpète
je sais pas tu penses qu'à mieux barrois
j'ai trop peut-être fou et 5 tu peut
retarder une perpétuation
j'ai fait un pays des 5 une récente note
la wii est repartie voir là bas mais bon
il fait même ça parce que je change des
tours je bouge c'est 2 je pense que il
ya des grosses qu'on pense même que
c'est suffisant ses deux pions pour la
call of may away il ya la paire de fou
bon menace quoi avec les noirs h chaque
instant un 15-4 matt josh 1,5 affiche
trois peut-être je gage 3h 4 3 bougez et
tour à utiliser en d5 tu contribues le
cadre est bon il peut faire annuler
après arrive à paris la passion par
mauvais résultats dans l'optique du
match pas un mauvais résultat irie garde
trois points d'avancé ils enchaînent et
il enchaîne ludique de large qui nous
dit trois points d'avancé en tout cas ça
sent bon
ouais ça sent bon c'est sûr que si tu
attaques les bullet avec +3 +4 tu force
de mec à faire une grosse une grosse
série à partir de plus 3 + 4 tu t'étais
de rendre bien pour le bullet comme je
disais tout à l'heure tu peux remonter 5
6 points mais pas plus donc quand tu
attaques à +3 +4 et bien quand tu
attaques à +1 plus de franchement ça
veut rien dire on est en vie du jeu si
tu veux n'a qu'un ouais ça si t'as pas
si t'as pas le dessus en fait plus un
plus de ça suffit pas pour
pour tenir davantage +3 +4 tu mets comme
une vraie pression
le mec est obligé de faire un truc quasi
parfait parce qu'au final on un plus un
en réalité en 30 minutes tu joues pas
tant que parti que sarah entre entre le
rajout de temps la seconde de rajouts et
le petit lag une partie septembre est en
fait pas plus de 10 donc pour faire plus
4 il faut gagner déjà 7 3 c'est quand
même un gros score 7-3 il ya six essais
si tu arrives à déjouer un puisque
parfois on est plutôt autour de 8-9
parti que disent donc ce qu'en fait si
tu es en plus un site est devant et que
tu veux faire traîner la partie tu peux
vraiment la faire traîner longtemps tu
joues j'ai sauvé à temps c'est pas très
pure play je connais un joueur qui fait
ça ces griots qui fait ça loana coeur si
oui bien sûr c'est juste et great food
qui avait inauguré le la manière de
faire contre maxime justement et away il
avait fait ça c'est insupportable et il
avait joué un truc genre roi pion de
l'âne foutu voix et il avait réussi à la
jouer pendant 150 coups un truc comme ça
il avancé leurs pions case par case tous
les quarante cinq coups donc tu peux la
jouer longtemps avec la seconde de rage
ou si tu fais ça pendant 150 coutu fait
traîner 5 6 minutes la finale
voilà implantée à franges et 5 et fouché
catch 72 j'ai montré ce qu'ils aient une
position un peu là quatre chansons que
je vais pour la case des cinq j'imagine
ouais du coup il ya quatre pions sur la
colonne la puissance 4 ça peut être très
fort page étrangers si c'est tu gagnes
et s'interrompt tellement mattel qui se
souvient du match great chouquet mvl et
qui dit que c'était tellement moche
ouais c'était dur à suivre pour nous tu
as une telle impression d'impuissance
quand c'est comme ça mais bon après
c'est dans les règles c'est dans les
règles je fais ce que tu veux
ces paroles ont l'esprit mais c'est dans
la règle en pluie sont assez cons à ses
copains great chouquet pmv elle ouais je
connais pas le rôle sans doute mais je
pense qu'ils sont tous qu'ils auront un
pote dans le haut niveau ouais après
tain qui sont peut-être plus spot que
que d'autres mais eux ils sont vraiment
potes on te demande si tu as besoin d'un
sponsor mise à part les déplacements
besoin de matériel ou autres te ment de
frost folle gaming awards a toujours
toujours besoin de sponsors on trouve
toujours des raisons de financer quelque
chose mais c'est surtout les
déplacements et les cours l'entraînement
de seconde en quoi pour faire simple ce
que j'aurai besoin d'un andy murray andy
fixe pour travailler mais j'ai pas la
place on apporte un petit appart
bon il est pas petit mais disons qu'un
ordi fixe j'ai déjà un ordi portable qui
que qui est pas donnée donc le fixe
avait vraiment la dif 1 je sais je sais
mais après c'est pour ça que j'ai en
seconde en plus ou moins tient bon en
diptyque ce fait j'ai surtout besoin
d'un second dans de quelqu'un qui
travaille pour moi plutôt que quand tu
dis plus ou moins seconde ans et c'est
moins que plus j'ai plutôt bien le
problème c'est que le projet c'est par
un problème c'est que c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure ni ça prend en
charge déjà ça donc j'ai pas besoin de
de quelque chose en plus tu as besoin
d'un commis de cuisine qui fait à manger
non ce que j'aime bien faire à manger
donc j'ai besoin de rien je besoin d'une
batterie électronique je voulais
m'acheter une batterie électronique une
patrie électronique
et oui on va prendre un nouvel os pour
aller donc en fait ses besoins qui sont
très loin des échecs en réalité en fait
j'ai juste besoin de me sentir bien dans
mon environnement
est ce qu'il faut obligatoirement bon
ordinateur pour s'entraîner sérieusement
de mansourah gants
non non non non après j'ai besoin d'un à
partir d'un certain niveau pour trouver
des idées dans les ouvertures je prends
bonne
autant te dicte à la place pour une
batterie mais pas pour un ordi oui parce
que commence allongés parce que si j'ai
un en disto acheter une tablette c'est
un peu la batterie je l'avais juste à
côté de mon piano c'est pas très haut
une batterie électronique coupe le son
c'est vraiment pas content je le rends
pas compte mais l'ordi leur dis de
maisons honnêtement depuis que j'en ai
un je pensais pas que ça faisait une
telle dit parce que j'étais comme toi
j'avais un gros portable et du monde un
gros portable et ça va tu va saper le
taf est en réalité depuis j'ai un gros
ordi maison bon déjà il est plus
puissant que le portable mais pas de
beaucoup
mais en réalité je pense que les
systèmes de les ventilos système de
refroidissement marche beaucoup mieux et
c'est genre ouais c'est plus puissant
c'est plus confortable pour leucan qc
plus puissants scéniquement la raison
pour laquelle j'en achète parce que mon
ordi portable me convient très bien
oui mais non c'est a réussi à mettre
alpha 0 dessus ou pas n'ont pas dit la
zéro non non non juste fiche clos si ya
pas mal de gens qui l'ont maintenant
cette alfa doit on peut le mettre l'île
à 0 mais qui a plus ou moins niveau
d'alpha 0 à présent ah oui ils
travaillent et peut-être mon ordi ne
pourra pas supporter ça en fait ça
dépend de ta carte graphique parce qu'il
marche sur la carte graphique a donc si
tu as un ordi gamer parce que tu te sens
gamer
l'attrait d'un gars n'est pas un
ordinateur à part boire un gros
processeur mais j'ai pas une carte
graphique extraordinaire choix j'ai
ainsi intel core i9 sur mon ordi ça
c'est bien pour stockfisch mais t'as pas
t'as pas une rose cartes graphiques
cartes graphiques cnj dia ma chambre
ouais je faisais porsche gtx je connais
même geforce gtx combien j'ai pas super
écrit sur le site et yeux tu peux nous
dire on a des spécialistes dans le chat
qui pourront te qui pourront donner un
coup de main est vraiment en fait tu
peux faire tourner les deux c'est ça le
gros avantage de justice a aussi pour
les gens qui sont dans le le chat c'est
que tu peux faire tourner du coup en
fait t'as stock fish qui tourne sur ton
sur ton nikkor 9 ouais ça flingue pas et
ça tu peux le faire tourner sur la carte
graphique donc tu peux avoir les deux
qui tournant
en parallèle après je ne sais pas avec
un portable si ça ça flingue pas au
niveau de la chaleur mais bon de toute
façon tu peux faire tourner un peu l'un
est un peu l'autre en fait ça fait
marcher deux composants complètement
différente ton ordi non mais pour le
coup tout ça pour finir que oui un ordi
fixe ça serait plutôt un bon
investissement oui aussi explorer 6 non
mais sans rigoler dans le chat tu peux
avoir des gens qui sont très
très influent pour en connaître certains
personnellement qu'ils pourront
peut-être se reconnaître que ce soit en
live ou en replay tu as des gens
vraiment influent qui suivent cette
chaîne faut le savoir c'est no fake fait
je peux je peux rien dévoiler en live
mais no fake tas de gens vraiment nom de
georges je peux pas je vais citer les
noms ni citer les postes mais tu as des
gens vraiment influent utilisent le web
et à l'arrière jaune lui tu sais mais il
ya d'autres gens influents
donc j'ai envie de te dire c'est un peu
une chaîne tu vois tu te dit tu sais pas
où tu mets les pieds quoi toi et tu
écrives emmanuel macron vient de claquer
son neuvième mois de save fans des
échecs impossible possible mais on ne
sait pas on ne lâchera pas de blaze
aujourd'hui donc cette position dans la
rade pendant qu'on discute d'ordinateurs
y ait eu plus 4 on a vu la victoire et
maxime continue qui continue sa marche
en avant quoi là il encore une position
tout à fait correct mais j'imagine en
tout cas complètement ok tu te disent
que si dsk nous suit comme il aime bien
les échecs qui te trouveras les bons
hôtels pour la logistique va être très
intéressant
on demande s'il vous prend des cas très
jouable écoute ça gagne un pion quoi
mais bon tu vas l'opposé des tours
pieusement mais bon c'est un essai ta
meilleure pièce non il échoua qu'à toi
donc qu'il va mettre la dame où il va
mettre la dame en b2c calcio cause parce
que mon bébé 4 et sur dame prend bekkat
va faire tout reprend b4 et il ya le
flou f4 qui défend la tour c'est un donc
ya pas de clouage après peut-être
maintenant il peut échanger en déca
temps s'il ya plus jeune société c'est
pas pareil il ya eu 2 qui tombe en plus
j'aurais pu le faire vous prendre qui on
prend dame prend tout reprend tout
reprend fou prend et tout reprendre de
zéro puis restauré tu viens tu vas fort
en afrique alors à wailly qui arrivent
plus un nom là il souffre il va pouvoir
reprendre ses études
donc il fait d'armes quand des quatre
qui est plutôt mince à lui permettra
enfin de variantes d'avoir la tour
anciens et pas en b 4 way pour couvrir
sa première rangée parents le font mal
placé mais dans tous les cas il va
perdre le pion à deux il ya égalité
matérielle
ouais mais tu as tout repenser 2e tour à
tour et l'agent refoulé 8 des six on en
a déjà vu maxime en perd notamment
contre contre magnus il a pas si
longtemps en face à des pions passé
comme ça hacker new york eût dit que le
speech est adulte c'est pas aussi simple
que le speech junior c'est le cas de le
dire c'est fini le junior ouais c'est
voyez qu'il a gagné il a notamment battu
fille ruth là tout le monde était fier
ou jaa favori moi je mettais plus tôt
wailly du coup je me suis pas trompé je
croyais qu'ils surestiment un peu fil
rouge à lèvres je pense que beaucoup de
gens auxquels sera très fort ça c'est
sûr mais l'heure actuelle
ok j'ai 5700 y'a pas à discuter on
demande si pour un second dans
l'important c'est vraiment une question
d'ordi ou c'est pas plus une clause une
question de compréhension humaine de la
position d'idées concrètes
je pense que c'est les deux mais tu vas
la même heure comme les franchement beau
très beau ordi ça aide tu gagner un
temps considérable
ce qu'on fait on travaille ensemble sur
une position précise et comme lui
lumbres ordi on propose des coûts et
l'ordi réfute direct dit que c'est bien
sans perdre de temps si je fais que mon
ordi je crois
parfois plus de temps qu'à et vous
utilisez stockfisch 10 puisqu'il utilise
un truc particulier il a dû régler le
programme à sa façon ce que gvg mu a
beaucoup de joueurs qui me disent qu'ils
n'aiment pas analysé avec stockfisch
disent qu'ils préfèrent le 8 a vraiment
j'entends souvent ce truc-là hockey
mineur - partir du moment où il donne
les bons coups a pas je sais qu'il ya
des corps dit qu'ils sont plus ou moins
plus ou moins une en face on aurait pu
chercher à faire du quai numéro un c'est
de faire tout rage 7 mai trois contes de
c'est facile c'est facile
maxime ça va il tient il tient bien là
et il a une petite un petit passage un
peu plus difficile face à oui mais il
réussit à apprendre les 2000 points
hyper plus quoi donc échanger les tours
évidemment ici c'est très mauvais
regardez les tours sur l'échiquier pour
défendre mais c'est assez simple de
faire nul ça tu fait nul à 100% s'est
posé aucun problème
on dit qu pas été analysés avec le nez
peau 2019
parce qu'il est trop rapide trop rapide
incroyable dans les gaps qui là qu'il a
commise
hélas trop vite il est enchaîné contre à
nantes c'était mignon quand même mais
bon eux donc d4 qui réussissent et 4g et
6 alors qu'il s'est trop cavalier f-35
maison ils ont vraiment le même
répertoire les deux majors grünfeld
pourquoi c'est apple aussi de l'or ce
qu'on me disait tout à l'heure
ouais même si deux joueurs même
répertoire plus ou moins même style de
jeu seulement le joueur français plus
fort c'est la seule différence entre les
deux oui complètement
uniquement parce qu'il est français en
fait c'est vraiment ça qui fait la
différence cers qui était si dur pour
toi j'ai j'imagine à chartres de jouer
que contre des français
ouais je pense que c'était une lettre
faisant vous dans mon fou encore un
français et coiffes et bah ils sont
forts ils sont forts ces français et
pour la coupe du monde tu as des
chouchous mise à part maxime et des
joueurs que tu aimerais bien voir
briller je moi je les auteurs français
comme bilel de la scène où
non ils vont ils vont être dans le drive
by sommes pas en français et je vais pas
pour le cas de france mais oui bryce
milson celui français quoi vous français
quand même avec la double nationalité
il n'y a pas de joueur qui te quitte
fonds spécialement rêver genre tu dis
lui on regarde son style franchement je
suis pas à par kasparov les autres
joueurs d'échecs ce j'ai jamais été en
admiration
il n'y a pas de joueurs qui t'a pas de
joueurs vraiment kit qui te font vibrer
quoi franchement assez marrant et à par
kasparov dans les joueurs anciens
joueurs des talent des médias kasparov
ont toujours forever c'est pas un
mauvais choix après ils te lire on est
pas mal alors cavaliers detroit
pour moi c'est jamais facile d'évaluer
ses positions je sais pas je sais pas
toi si tu as evans
je pense que des plans sont mieux tu vas
b3 déjà ça plaise aux questions
concrètes prises prise quand tu penses
que le centre 3d qu'at-il fort que le
hac qu'elle fout là c'est un petit plus
blanc lorsque tu vois je 4 kg 5
c'est désagréable jeu pour lui et pour
le nord c'est exactement ce qui fait
d'ailleurs accueilli ces cinq ans à
venir avec le thème polka et b6
peut-être mal placée en plus c'est
toujours difficile je trouve d'évaluer
les positions et à des cavaliers
comptent des fous attali au total la
diva se faire une petite vidéo
d'explication
tu rigoles de faire une vidéo
d'explication de 8h30 petit oui là il ya
un cas spécial et là le gpat elle mais
qu il n'a rien compris quoi bien ce que
je disais mais que 27 50 kw à savoir la
vidéo d'explication la gueule du truc
avait donc no fake tu vas avoir accès tu
vas avoir accès ce soir à el fahm aux au
dvd sur le puits
isolé 7h du mat comme volumes sur des
pianos les doigts en même temps c'est
génial je peux te dire oui ils sont
vraiment très très lu lé ses joueurs à
27,50 je ne peux pas arriver à moins de
2780 mais je pense que ça les aide
n'empêche de penser que les autres
joueurs sont plus ou moins nul ne
comprennent rien 27 ouais parce qu'à un
moment donné en fait comme tu joues
contre des mecs vraiment très fort en
face de toi si tu ne le penses pas à un
moment donné qu'ils sont pas plus à moi
je trouve sans problème c'est qu'il joue
contre des mecs très fort mais tout le
temps les mêmes et je suis sûr que s'il
faisait des six faisait des d'open
classique avec des 26 50 voire indien
par exemple de noter les 25-50 indien et
je suis pas sûr qu'ils gagneraient tour
je pense qu'ils perdraient beaucoup de
points ce serait intéressant de le voir
je suis plutôt que de voir tout le temps
les mêmes tournois fermé avec les mêmes
joueurs évidemment ils sont très forts
mais j'aimerais bien savoir comment
utiliser brevet contre les petits
indiens de tu vois des quinze ans le
petit sory n'est pas pour te dire nous
d'un point de vue spectateurs par
rapport au tour de haut niveau on pense
on pense exactement la même chose que
toi c'est à dire que tu vas avec les
tontons là on regarde un peu les
tournois les signes que phil capé et
compagnie au bout d'un moment il y en a
juste marre de voir pour la septième
fois de l'année m.duhamel contre carole
scène pourtant c'est une belle affiche à
bnc ça un moment donné c'est un peu too
much
ça évite match tu as envie de tata envie
de les voir contre des joueurs moins
forts entre guillemets en tout cas sur
le papier et puis voir voir ce que ça
donne clairement très clairement mais
très clairement par exemple de voir dans
un event comme ça c'est beaucoup plus
sympa pour le public
j'ai juste dû au non mais même même si
tête le pousse et tu vois genre grande
chaise sur paris on a un mec comme toi
en fait on sais pas peut-être que tu vas
te faire tu vas te faire laver et puis
ça va nous faire marrer le vrai haut
niveau je crois c'est long et ou
peut-être pas le niveau est au contraire
tu fais des surprises et du coup ça fait
kif
et de se dire oui mais ce que c'était
une surprise ou whisky confirmera mais
au moins ça mais un enjeu
quand ça mais quelque chose et mais
comment rien à perdre face à des gens ou
et puis quand on parlait du match tout à
l'heure de kasparov karpov il disait
dans les interviews que ça l'avait
beaucoup aidé de jouer beaucoup de
parties contre kharkov ça la fait
progresser en réalité kasparov donc
peut-être qu en ouvrant le circuit tu
veux aussi progressé des mecs qui vont
qui vont rejoindre l'élite après c'est
très clairement pas je vois par exemple
ne jamais voir un mec comme artemiev
c'est très frustrant puis c'est oui
c'était le nom que j'ai citées récemment
quand j'avais ce cette discussion
portait mieux feu c'est sûr qu'ils
feraient résultat les tops mondiaux
ouais puis ça permettrait de voir ce
qu'il vaut après la ddcs c'est peut-être
une chance pour lui de pas ne pas
participer si tôt parce qu'ils pensent
que son répertoire est encore un peu
léger
lens a rien après un oui mais au moins
ça permettrait de le voir est en tout
cas pour le public ce serait cool à
force ça se change en dise et que ça oui
ça se travaille ça se fait évoluer mais
bon ça pète si simple à ce niveau-là de
d'avoir un répertoire d un cadre et donc
maxime est ce que tu penses que ça va à
la de nouveau c'est un peu un genre de
mail et tactique
non mais ça va je fous tu trouves une
case
il valait ou en c1 eux hunt je pense
ces loups six ours et 5 h cup finalement
le roi qui est mon temps j'ai cinq qui
se sera pas fait à mettre sous pression
et là il peut même revenir en dessin
akouè normes et +5
il reste combien de temps il reste y
reste humide c'est la dernière partie en
trois plus un maxime et après sept buts
après c'est le bullet mais si tu tournes
à +5 ces bons même plus 4 en fait ça y
est assez bien juste s'il fait tourner
la pendule pour qui pour être sûr qu'ils
aient pas d'autres partis qui fait nul
au pire et c'est bon je pensais que ce
serait plus chérèque se bat surtout
surtout surtout à la fin des 5 minutes
un way sorti un moment donné on pensait
que ce serait pas serré mais mais pour
d'autres raisons quoi là il est quand
même impérial il est facile des cinq
sens il est vraiment très bien avec le
petit décalage qu'on a sur la pendule
officielle à mon avis le temps pour le 3
minutes est passé et maxime nom qui va
qui va tourner avec un avantage
la seule question c'est de savoir
combien faut quand même faire gaffe de
passe se faire réseauter un moment donné
tu es tu au 30 juin genre tours fc tours
g7 ou g8 tu vois quelque chose comme ça
rocher de tours 8
on a tous rage sept tours 8 jouer
est-ce si simple de trouver un coup la
wii qui a réussi à bien à bien mettre le
roi noir en danger quand même fait
tomber deux c'est bien joué surtout
resserré à cavalier e 2 et surtout rêve
du et qui est 4 imagine à ça et c'est
parti dans le c'est parti dans la mêlée
tactique
alors lequel quel message a fait rire le
dernier le petit je vais pas le petit
gildas te dit un contre jour léger léger
et maximiles
il est tellement tranquille viager cents
à rêver non ça c'est alors chez cindy 26
fonds oui mais la souffrance et 2 pour
le moment quand même il peut faire tour
ces deux tours des cinq tours prend 1,2
et faire nul pour ces deux tours des
sacs tout dessein que je dire caïds et 5
et tout a changé d'aile peut-être tour
des deux nouvelles années nos laideurs
soutenir l économie chercheurs et sur
les castrais fuite
il va faire cavalier avec 5 j'imagine je
suis prise prise échec et aux hadjis
foulée trois jeux par contre à quoi ça
servait de façon la tourelle var qui
veut garder la journée ça c'est très
dangereux non ben oui je suis aussi il
va gagner le pion c2l s'ils gagnent
c'est gagner qu'avec elle prouvait trois
qui sont logiques tout et prend b3
encore plus simple voile et doit prendre
ces deux lieux où il peut mais il va pas
gagner deux pions ou maintenant ça va
peut-être se révèle la pro b trois ans
visant à masquer en fait siphonné sénat
il y avait 600 prises ouais bon nom qui
tourne à plus 5
et maintenant c'est le garder c'est
l'heure des bulles est donc une nouvelle
petite pause maxime tu veux récupérer et
on va passer dans des bulles est mais on
voilà on est ronde et très en retrait
pose là toute une petite pause mois si
j'allais prendre un verre d'eau je te
laisse sa plume en attendant donc un
match un peu décousu avec un début de
match difficile pour le joueur français
qui était mené et puis finalement
finalement joueurs français qui qui
vient de marquer avec les allumettes +9
en réalité mais il vient juste de
l'écraser il vient juste de remonter
neuf points sans courrier puisse gagner
une seule partie en faisant des nuls au
milieu mais sans qui hélas un lacet une
seule une simple victoire du joueur
chinois donc un joueur chinois très
dominés un joueur chinois très dominés
donc il est du coup 18h50 alors je vous
poser une petite question genre profit
c'est ce que vous voulez après qu'on
suive un petit peu gary ensemble sur sur
la chaîne bitstream du cou où on fait
une pause on se retrouve demain à voir
bon je vais m non pas l'échiquier je me
suis planté je vais mettre ça en reçu je
veux remettre ça au dessus
peut-être se faire un début de carrière
voire une une ou deux ensemble on va
voir après le problème c'est que j'aurai
pas forcément de temps pour pour faire
les vidéos youtube qui doivent sortir ça
peut être un peu ton tendu d'ailleurs
loach est une question à te poser
directement donc je vais le faire
pendant cette pause
vu que c'est censé être une pub donc
j'ai envie de te dire tu veux on peut en
profiter est ce que est ce que tu as pu
recevoir
je t'ai envoyé ce matin j'ai pu envoyer
le le dvd avec vlad finalement comme tu
as vu j'ai trouvé un moyen de le mettre
en ligne qui me paraissaient convenable
je sais pas si tu as eu le temps de de
l'ouvrir site à site a réussi
et si ça marche bien de ton côté et si
ça s'ouvre bien si tous ouvrent bien
parce que j'ai pas j'ai pas de retour
encore c'est la deuxième personne fois
je l'envoyer à buzz c'est à toi
du coup les deux personnes qui devait le
recevoir et donc j'en profite à temps de
faire leur tour sur discorde intéressant
ça marche nickel ok c'est super c'est
super c'est une très bonne nouvelle
c'est une très bonne nouvelle
donc on voit un peu les partis qui sont
en train de jouer sur czech comme
bortnik qui joue en ce moment pour moi
ce que je vais faire c'est que j'allais
chercher un petit verre d'eau et je vais
revenir je vais revenir tout de suite a
tout de suite les mecs
je suis de retour les mecs donc salut la
compagnie savez monsieur pessoa c'est
fini ça recommence c'est presque fini
monsieur pessoa et après du coup on
enchaînera peut-être avec un stream sur
gary on va voir on va essayer de on va
essayer de viser les sommes un peu ce
mois ci quand je peux stream essayer de
monter aux essais une montée au 309 sais
pas si c'est jouable
si vous êtes si vous suivez la chaîne
pour la première fois ici même n'hésitez
pas à mettre un petit un petit follow ça
fait plaisir ça fait toujours plaisir
bien évidemment et demain soir on sera
de retour
on sera d'autant je crois que c'est à 16
heures je vais vous dire ça tout de
suite je vais regarder l'horaire du
match on va regarder l'horaire du match
on va regarder ensemble
enfin ensemble je vais regarder de mon
côté maxime qui est en train de revenir
maxime qui est de retour maxime cette
première expérience de de commentaire du
coup ça donne quoi
écoute c'est sympa a pas trop long parce
que c'est un match un peu long tu avais
un poil long canon c'est ça doit être
surtout le nom de rod je me donne trois
heures mais ouais c'est un poil longue
ça va permettre selon les enjeux fait
des retours à thiès comme pour la guerre
que c'est trop long je serai que 3e
je trouve que quelque chose entre 1h45
et 2h30 ce serait bien personnelle et
d'ailleurs c'est plus que trois heures
soit trois heures et demie n'ont au
final ouais c'est trois heures de jeu
effectif eu en gros mais oui savait plus
à 3h15 3h20 de jeu et 3h30
enfin on a des pauvres plus longue
qu'avant
et donc demain il ya le match
nepomniachi danielian j'ai envie de te
dire c'est pas la plus belle affiche et
tu vas comment take est bien fait
comment tu es tout seul ni toi bien haut
autant dire que mon objectif sera de
voir le plus gros score de l'histoire du
speech s
j'espère voir un 30,0 personnellement
c'est faisable amont et bien signer peau
est sérieux mais paul est pas sérieux
c'est sa marque de fabrique et le si sûr
à duda guiry ça c'est pas mal comme
affiche belle affiche et après ça vous
parle
alors après il y aura peut-être duarte
énième gritche mais ça va dépendre de la
coupe du monde donc ya pas de date
officielle encore mais le 1er octobre il
ya un match intéressant aronian sirou
déjà ah ouais c'est pas mal aussi des
belles affiches comme le 2 il ya
mamediarov so sion et le 3 il ya un haka
murat d'oberhof pas non plus au hockey
et je pourrais pas le commenter nakamura
de broc malheureusement parce que je
serai normalement dans l'avion pour
moscou
c'est déjà la beauce coup d'ailleurs
deux fois mais il ya longtemps
bon je vous salue tour un échec autant
d'échecs par équipes par nation je sais
plus quand il s'appelait du coup à
l'époque du coup j'avais je continuerai
lilly company j'avais 13 ans et 12 ans
c'était vraiment longtemps sata lessard
bons souvenirs ouais ouais ouais ouais
j'étais trop jeune pas savourer tous les
plaisirs de moscou mme la différence ils
ont un certain âge pour savourer les
plaisirs de notre coup tu sens qu'il ya
des plaisirs qui cédera aux dix mois et
oui je vous rappelle la place rouge
c'est sympa et la deuxième fois c'était
l'année d'après au même endroit même
compétition est sympa ça devait être
voir copie qui organise et ça et voilà
ça s'appelle comme ça raconte
donc j'étais venu vous voir jouer ah
ouais on sera pas à moi ça c'est sûr
j'étais pas assez j'étais passé voir ça
je sais plus pourquoi je te laisse
d'ailleurs points forts comme compétents
oui il y avait des belles équipes que
des jeunes et que des jeunes 1er juin
c'était peut-être en marge de billets
l'arrière la dia la tour blanche mais
une compétition scolaire
non c'était une belle complète je crois
que ça ils organisent plus je pense que
ça a eu quelques quelques éditions et
malheureusement ça s'est arrêté mais
c'est assez sympa à l'occasion retourner
c'est une belle ville pour les échecs
c'est bien l'anecdote l'équipe chinoise
on est invités un concert de george
michael
donc c'était pas mal a invité par la rue
et l'équipe chinoise à 21h est parti se
coucher
ils ont raté le concert raté c'est
qu'ils sont arrivés ça commence et
peut-être à 20h40 termites plus tard ils
sont partis ce que je sais pas intéressé
par en fait c'est le sait les oratoires
la chinoise tu vas te coucher à 7h20 et
tu t'es passé par là et c'est fou fou il
y avait les huits yong et compagnie
c'est un aller-retour live at the row et
c'était à cette époque donc il avait été
déjà fort et après je crois qu'il avait
arrêté de jouer pendant deux ans un truc
comme ça il est revenu il est passé dans
le set
je pense que pendant deux ans il a bossé
à fond les echets il est revenue 27 des
joueurs d'exception un séjour
d'exception mais aussi tu dois avoir
territoire et d une grosse émulation
dans ces pays là parce que si tout le
monde et 27,50 enfin 27 27 55 ans j tout
le monde pas tout le monde bien
évidemment mais tous les joueurs de ta
génération il arrive à 27
ça doit créer une émotion une émulation
qui est beaucoup plus forte et ça doit
rendre
j'ai pas envie dire plus facile mais ça
va être plus motivant pour travailler
c'est possible après vraiment de la
chine c'est particulier donc je sais pas
si je sais dans les autres pays
peut-être mais la différence en tant que
les chrétiens à lens accès particulier
et était déjà allé en chine du goût
alors j'ai fait en données cvs est noble
mais pas la chine et j'aimerais mais
elle est sans doute mon prochain voyage
tu peux éventuellement peut-être trouvé
une équipe d'ailleurs
ouais je l'évité je vais contre les
petits chinois 23 51 qu'est ce qui s'y
joue à 26
[Musique]
c'est vrai ils sont pas mauvais et le
petit buy in china ou j'ai pu lesquels
ils sont dans le beh web haïti chine
avait battu au calme non je sais que bah
quoi est fait jouer pour une équipe
chinoise il était revenu avec -15 points
bas étaient écoeurés dur mais en
indonésie c'est dur aussi non non la
donne et si c'était pour pas pour les
sécher acquitté pour en retrait oui donc
c'est plus intéressant ce que dit vos
lots on habille sais pas non plus top
l'indonésie donc à maxime cas peut-être
faire une petite deux cavaliers et ben
voilà c'est il va sortir des prix bas et
faire tenir lieu de avec des jouets des
trois est maintenant kg 3 il reprend 2 f
il avait joué comme ça contre nac à
l'asim que fils je crois mecs ef prend
pas trop tu retombes vraiment dans un
genre de française avec le four ans et 8
bloqués et tu laisses le pion des cats
mais tu très bien le pion de 5 et
attaque le roi non mais c'est une bonne
idée de torture
ouais c'est une variante sympa c'est
marrant de sympa à jouer il va récupérer
le pion des 4 et si tu joues avec grand
qui va s'ouvrir la lhdaa mais si tu
joues avec thé rox a pas tout
la loi contre michael avait une bonne
position mais il n'avait pas réussi à
conclure de mémoire bref elle qui joue
un dommage qu'à un moment il n'a pas
joué ouais voilà d'abord face à leur
écran en deux ans la dame a annoncé 6 et
à b5 et il ya plus de cases 6
c'est une boucherie maintenant wayne on
a on arrive dans la zone le match
j'avais déjà gagné pour le joueur
français qui rejoint de karo kann alors
tu as que c'était vraiment un mystique
ou est ce que c'est ce qui va nous
rendre hommage et faire une robe je
pense pas il a eut fait une fois mais
c'était un match contre zoug
mais ces femmes qui regardaient le match
en même temps et comme le match était
gagné il a écrit où il fait une grotte
ce qu'on sait plus quoi dire sur le
match quoi du coup il avait joué le jeu
ils avaient fait la grève
tu vois c'était pas un risque l'icac
araucanie la joue vraiment ouais
peut-être que c'est un signe pour pour
les compétitions à venir tôt bien qu'ils
ont de plus hélas karo kann c'est sûr
très solide un statut peut avoir
l'impression que tu es blanc un avantage
de développement c'est le cas mais c'est
très difficile à percer puisqu'un pas de
faiblesse à faux par said bey iv p 500
s'est adjugé 7 food avait ici j'ai 5
ok rock
5 c'est gênant mais tu veux juste faire
fouet si ça va aller ça va paradis quoi
qu'on fait si je bouffe et ou resserrant
je venais surprendre tour chez soi y
avait quatre c'est vrai que ça va je
suis d'accord avec toi on ça devient un
peu chiant ça commence à devenir un peu
dur mais tu adaptes des huit la madame
david beckham
bref on prend h4 f6
je mange tout bon jeu j'avais vu ses 7
et surtout f4 ont tiré quatre noms 1
il s'active effectivement il a beaucoup
de tourments gif six pattes membres de
différents prix va peut-être récupérer
la deux pions de moins il va peut-être
les récupérer il récupère 1
quand on trouve ces huit courses et un
tour c'est le pire il en récupère qu'un
soin d'eux mais à tout prendre russie ce
qui rôde aussi bon le jeu suit remettez
en fait chaud au coeur c'est le film ça
m'avait poussé six tours j'ai deux rois
h3 ouais mais je vous sais si ce que je
fais tour sa bulle ce qui veux pas
mettre la tour en b non madame je vais
fogel matelas que je le réseau est
choquée at-elle froid elle est il
complètement fermée de toute façon c'est
un gagneur je pense pour moi j'ai
l'impression que certains qu'il réussit
pas à mettre la marche avant exception
je me suis fait à 6-6 a toujours tout
reprend mais ici c'est bessette tu peux
jamais donc on va juste faire tourbe et
5 peut-être à temps maximal il a trouvé
un truc non je pense qu'ils les deux
olympiques le zappeur points 5
mais même sa forme cinq rois g3 foucher
4 sur tours jeu se met à risque
spécifique de l'autre coûtera magazine 7
à 6 score on s'est foutu mais bon il
s'est un peu raté ça fait quoi ça fait
toujours plus 5
il reste 25 minutes en faut pas faire
n'importe quoi non plus hein le hockey
est passé à côté mais h4 il croque c'est
pour ça que je dis faux pas faut pas
être complètement relâché il faut encore
faire un tout petit effort pour pour
fermer la porte et puis après bon après
c'est pas mauvais ce qui fait le jeu
avec h5 a aidé 5 ou là on me sort c'est
normal
lâche trop d'erreurs mais ce n'est pas
justement rue pour les noirs sa nouvelle
j'ai toujours l'impression qu'en face se
fout bloquant h5 a expliqué est sûre tu
es là là ya du avoir de taxi coop fosse
3 md 2,4
il veut jouer quatre forces nommer les
quelque 4.911 petit super forme avec les
idées qu alger 4 je pensais ça fait
quatre chemins je pensais que calculer
ça en fait que justin pions pour 9,5 non
mais là parce que là il ya ça de gagné
dames si ce n'est pas du banc dès lors
on n'aurait pas raison on va retourner
sur la partie de ce qu'on est parti loin
il va réussir à faire j'ai quatre et
gagner le fou c'est sûr ça se profile un
ouais c'est bien ça lui permettrait de
fermer le match quoi il veut des vaches
quatre échecs et croit jamais pourquoi
simplifie tout ce qui doit être bien
aussi donc moins 5 annoncé un truc qui
vend des cats il le prend il fait un peu
de rock non mais c'est peut-être pas six
ans le thé c'était non mais je serais
allé dans le détroit d'un machin je
pense qu'il veut tout sur la poésie et
petit seulement peur de perdre roewe dam
des trois c'était courageux touchant
même gic est surtout j'ai 15e tour h 3
kg dames b3 avait tiré lieu c'est le bon
regarde ça c'est une boucherie
wen et il suffit juste de trouver
comment comment finir le quart temps a
été plutôt que le tout reste 5 tours à
chaque c'est facile et tourcoing c'était
fini ouais
tant pis si libé il y met autant plus
est à plus de temps pour y aller bouffer
roef depuis on ne prend plus au sérieux
cette et f5 la partie qui durera il veut
nous trouver un beau matin il trouve
normes et wall e contre je regarde les
irlandais en v2 une harley g8 et
détourage schiste très bien et
maintenant tour qui ont autour des six
pompiers pensaient peut-être plus
précieux avant qu'il y avait des chèques
et 2 et cette fois ci c'est fini roi 2
tu finis
on apprend à prendre des allures
d'événement 2 et pour eux deux c'est
bien jouer puisqu'ils forcent pas
prendre loin des 35 tour avec 5 voix ses
filles +6 et il reste tu vois la salle à
manger beaucoup de temps plus il reste
vingt minutes à manger quatre minutes
d35 ça il enroule yvan oui s'amuse à
trois c'est déjà retarde highfield
option que les problèmes ne cessait-il
tous les deux seront tilt a hélas at-il
tu me lis et qui se finit donc je peux
plus le match est gagné là il se sera
fait peur quand même un add on va
peut-être devoir d'aider votre truc
c'est de voir un gros abattage marine
grecque ti est ce que ça a déjà vu un
stream de maxime pour rapidement mais
pas pourquoi non comme ça par chris
paget si mes parents en entier mais
peut-être fou au f5 la non pensée coup
avec cinq copains qui sait de serre les
super forme
grâce à leur férocité qu'atom la force à
la wii toujours poker fait liste change
pas ou c4 est ce qu'il ya vraiment un
truc maximum et le rock
ouais nan oui poker face mais même le
match perdu il encore tranquille
maxime qui est vraiment fort il est
vraiment bon c'est il a du mal à cela
deux ans mais c'est partir mais je
trouve que c'est d'autant plus
impressionnant au final des matches
comme ça mais une grosse baisse de
régime de la part de wei a pas eu
seulement en et ford à bord du maxi il
ya eu les deux mais c'est souvent lié 1
2 mais on sent quand même que c'est plus
tu vas y les langues
ouais j'ai l'impression que ça lui il
continue à demander qu'on les qualités
ses chances pour le match d'aujourd'hui
oui il a dit qu il estimé ses chances à
0.99 pour ce en quoi il a dit ça en tout
petit peu en dessous de 1%
donc ça m'étonne pas s'il était voici
s'il est déjà sous l'emprise de la
domination de maxime salle alsace pas
que dès que ça commence a mal tourné en
fait ça là découragés
je pensais qu'avec trois ça c'est pas
mal aussi
kafka de retrouver la belle façon en
ligne en juin comme moi j'essaie aussi
se faire enlever les 3es projet donne à
quel point je tourne assez joli ça
contre pointe
ça fait plus cette presse est je pense
que c'est mathématiquement gagné maxime
donc pour pour ton premier match aller
va faire un an il aurait pu faire une
grob là ils auraient pu lâcher la grave
le tilt complet du web
il n'en peut plus on se pose des bills
non mais là mais même s'ils gagnent tout
il n'y arrivera pas c'est sept points
c'est trop tentant
il reste 17 minutes
17 minutes tu vas faire six parties max
normalement et encore et encore il faut
les gagner vite
c'est sur le même problème à une partie
qui durent t'as vu tout à l'heure c'est
4 minutes 30 1 donc pour pour gagner
vite fait plaisir d'être sacrifiée il
s'en fout hein il fait le beau jeu là
j'suis pas sûr qu'il ait vu un but la
moue qui fait regarder aller
connaissant le personnage ici les
plaisirs il envoie alors lui dit qu'il
pense qu'on va avoir une grave l'afld
lui demander provost s'est pas assez
hommage qui stream pas en même temps
pour lui demander mais là il vous
faudrait fabien qu'il aurait fallu
écrire pendant la pause une grande s'il
te plaît dans gérer mais j'ai pas cher
qu'ailleurs
normalement il a pour croire fait
attention on risque la disqualification
après je pense que personne et on
voudrait si le sait regarder mais et on
aurait dû y penser pendant la pause
après personne ne lui en tiendra rigueur
a vu que le match est fini
bon alors y'a pas du foie fuite ici mais
il est dans le dur là quand même ça
lâche et annonce qu'il a peur
ja pas dans quel monde il sauve sa gaffe
à tes dessins quand même
là tu vois gigot atteint alors f-35
celle un peu plus le trou noir
22.6 tu vois droid 7 sél a joué thème
pour la paix lors des beaux réseaux de
bots menacer damas est mat
tu vois il a bouffé environ 3 600 pas
encore roger 2 tours 3 hockey ouais mais
bon voilà on s'est fié à rien de pareil
oui mais encore la joue un petit peu
quand même
tu as du talent g8 m embête c'est pas
fait encore un fois faut qu'ils
réussissent à créer une menace ballon g3
j'envisagerai drôme la manif damoclès
qui reviennent avec intermédiare hillary
carnet jour chinois et toujours aucune
réaction
s'il a rigolé là il s'en est sans les
doigts agiles et dont il est il est dans
le mal là il est dans le mal oui c'est
incroyable comment ce match est retourné
quand même 1 2 puis 2 puis finalement
moment comme une nation complète a
l'impression que si maxime avait appuyé
sur l'accélérateur dès le début ça
aurait pu faire un massacre au total une
différence de niveau fin ces gamins
crois que quand tu penses que oui il est
dans le top 30 mondial après là on parle
de k danse classique moi je pense y
croyez ça laisse battre plus dans les
cadences rapides
non parce qu'elle est un très bon joueur
de bullet n'ya pas d'armée il ya
incroyable mpm quand ici ouais quand tu
veux bien jeu il est irrésistible en ce
pitch est si là il allait il a eu du mal
à après contre
contre grid chouquer contre 1 k o n'a
qu'à mais c'est des joueurs quand même
d'un autre calibre
1 pour le courrier pour le coup et bien
sûr mais pour le coup là toujours dumas
le comte takao je trouve oui bah c'est
un peu maxime j'ai pas envie de re max
et ensuite je dirais que maxime a un peu
plus je sais pas complet à une grotte je
sais pas en acajou et revoilà il a fait
une attaque spike enfin enfin des vrais
échecs sur sur ce match mais tu l'as pas
écrit no fake un non je n'ai pas écrit
en vie mais je t'ai dit qu'il avait à
faire
c'était sûr ici savait qu on commenté
c'était sûr qu'il a créé une robe on le
connaît notre maxime aillent nous a fait
plaisir là dessus tu vois c'est ça leur
déjà c'est déjà un avantage avantage
blanche pense franchement il a mené
plaisent à tout et qui joue dan jean
pierre davant pour apprendre et savoir
en plusieurs
ouais mais c'est l'esprit de la grande
lycée il connaît il connaît ses
classiques 1 et on gère un kiosque à toi
bon ça
après f4 plutôt de me b 4 je suis pas
sûr qu'ils ne le sait mais c'est rien
pour le coup je suis pas sûr qu'ils mais
ça va bientôt y à rien et rien qu'à
relief trois tons g1 tu te replaces
beurre et les deux colonnes berne c'est
wake on lan des colonnes j'aimerais
d'ailleurs dénonçant on sent qu'il a
envie de jouer en pro de chez sig avec
nous demain tu as il veut se faire
remarquer tu vois il nous montrait les
mecs j'ai quand même lui niveau je suis
dans l'esprit j'ai envie de vous
rejoindre
chaque épreuve 6 car il est proche des
six fou prend f5 et d'un premier
cavalier cet échec assez à dassault
vient d'avaler fièrement n'importe quoi
oui bon bah ouais mais bon il est face à
une grosse équipe soudée trop il revient
nero d'objet en objet change peu près
move et du cou
fouad el cheikh station de surkh loin
qu'elle prend 1,4 la quête c'est
toujours mal de se faire de se faire
masser par un groupe comme ça c'est une
souffrance ni l'a pas gagné une fortune
en bus la thur non il n'en peut plus là
et regards il fait la grande aussi qu il
en peut plus quoi c'est génial des
groupes de partout si oui j'ai mauricie
maintenant le droit de fouler cette
ouverture interdite
ah oui là il en a gagné une en bullet a
effectivement envoyé 1 1 mais c'est beau
tout ses crocs quand même ce magnifique
mais une mode qui s'est lancée un
vraiment avec la grande adage hulk il
ajoute qu'elle prend des notes
j'en prends ces produits qui gagnait
tout de suite mais bon après il a
l'esprit de la grave avec lui oui
celle-là tu vois la tech
non mais c'est pas si mal
will happen of pas comme ça devient le
brésil cheikh l'attend rasoir est en
train de voir des vrais partis ça ne
fait que ça te fait quoi en fait de voir
enfin des vrais partie d'échecs je serai
au précieux pas impressionné avec bon
après c'est avec toi aussi tu as un
représentant des vrais échecs dont tu
connais j'ai fait quelques go ainsi que
7,5 tonnes celle dont je le rappelle
vraiment j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure
mais c'est celle en pro che smic contre
contre l'islande et c'était fantastique
tu étais tellement foutu c'est
magnifique
les trois 3 jours - je crois je l'avais
commenté pour repêcher que ça paye avec
un piège en plus dans la position
ouais non à ce moment là c'était pas si
certaines deux victoires pour la grotte
quand même si ça je dis rien a encore
ça y est alors faut vraiment que vous
allez avec les nôtres bitstream sur sur
le live officiel leur mettre des petits
g4 de partout heil en plus on a une tour
qui avance latéralement ceibal des 5es
sacrifice de tours ouais les 14 points 4
les cases blanches extraordinaire lots
n'ont pas toujours aussi moche que ça me
paraissait quand même plus précis allez
donne la cger en fait la grotte ça tu
commencé en fait tous les gens sont
hypnotisés quand ils ont tous envie de
la jouer en 4 4
donc on en est où il reste combien de
temps dans ce match on va voir combien
de groupes encore et asi minutes je
pense qu'on va avoir un fou le grand
bain pour le moment la grande n'a pas
perdu encore que d avoir bavé va gagner
seul l'argent vers le chef catalan après
ils font que j'ai 4 h 50 la meilleure si
ce non sens je pense qu il va y va lui m
j'ai peur qu'il la perde mais c'est pas
ça qu'est il ya du ce week-end prochain
si cela sa part qu'il prend 1,6 frapru 6
pour congés cette île séparée
il peut prendre quatre à l'arrière et je
vous prends schiste mans d'affaires tour
h7 non il n'ya pas cavalier bout juste
quatre écrans
il est bien il sait bien organisés fou
des quatre tours troyes pour sortir du
cloud âge et on va avoir le droit à une
petite frousse bête pour comprendre
cette presqu'île a chip et tout reprend
g7 le plus facile
oui mais pas sur mais bon au revoir qui
bien là tout en fuite catastrophique
alors là c'est j'arrête le point
où les foules et 5 c 4 à tour 5 bien
joué non mais les mets toi pas tout il
s'est planté pas tout cas précis cela va
donner dans son blog qu'elle est à des
positions de nul de maxime donc à encore
à temps mince magnifique c'était cadré
ok j'ai recadré qu'elle g4 g5 h4 assez
extraordinaire c'est du troll mais je
voyais ai pas je voyais pas oui partir
dans les groupes comme ça quoi
maxime ça m'étonne pas il est dans le
délire mais je voyais pas ouï dire
entrer dans le jeu identique sera
complètement tous c'est incroyable je
m'aime plus est il a une petite chute il
reste combien de temps elle il lui reste
deux parties normalement c'est là une
autre et c'est fini on compte 15
secondes pour jacques et cette fois
puisque rennes rennes je parle de nous
sur la foule cinq lycées de rennes je
parle de nous sur le live officielle à
l'issue issue wrench il comprend lé
influence internationale de la chaîne
par mais c'est beau
par pays c'est que maxime it roll is et
que maxime il suit un peu la chaîne
français cas juste b5 et d'amd ça c'est
quoi leur informateur et une tour de mon
nom va être de plus il va lui refaire
une grave insulte annonce non on va on
va finir par être connue pour ses graves
en france on aura quand même quelques
spécialistes
on a bien sûr le plus grand d'entre
d'entre tous mes 10 à lui la joue
carrément long il s'en fout sais pas
comment il fait mais le ticket le 3 way
ça va être joli up a eux c'était sûr ça
fait plus 10 à il a arrêté
il en a eu marre là il va il va faire en
notre temps notre troll
je pense qu'ils la ferment a mis le feu
au deuxième tour mais ça c'est beaucoup
plus fort déjà que la grave ben je pense
aussi à jessains tanneur cie louis
regard il faut pas faire comprendre les
5 maxime il va faire route au salaire et
henry moore de rêve voilà ils content il
est très heureux
hugo dans ulysse resort est quadri c'est
génial c'est fantastique je pense que
daniel il arrive plus à commenter ce qui
se passe ça il va suer bon nous on a
l'habitude de faire n'importe quoi mais
il doit il doit pas savoir quoi dire
quoi les désirs oui c'est un événement
très sérieux et tout et les mecs font
n'importe quoi
il doit suer de fou sur le live officiel
c'était le top mondial qui joue voilà
est vraiment n'importe quoi
extraordinaire
il est tellement fier de lui fier de sa
connerie c'est magnifique mais bon bravo
à lui un voyage en asie là il peut
mériter de de s'amuser un peu et disent
qu'ils ont eu six sur chelsea tv
bah ouais mais bon confronté à de gaulle
les échecs à ces visites qui commente
enfin ces visites qui compte sur externe
scène mais bon nous sommes des
spécialistes mondiaux de la grotte
qu'est ce que tu veux passer à presser
le pas pour mon écoute j'ai parfois
qu'on a discuté en plus s'il a les
candidats et tout ça il jouera peut-être
qu'à un ou deux matches du coup aurait
pu peut-être d'autant plus pas envie de
s'occuper d'une équipe
ouais puis bon à vrai dire on est quand
même plus fun non mais là c'est beau il
va faire x 3 x 3 donne des cadres la
rocket iii qu'un jeune c'est parfois bon
pour le coup il est peut-être mal gamme
wii donc en fait c'est par an 100 ça
devait tendre scène je pense pourtant
surtout prend bekkat la tour d un mat
quand même qui m'est inquiètent ils les
voient ça mais ça par contre donné 2
passes ont entouré de ce qu'il a vécu en
jeu fera pas de maths et la fenps un peu
oui tout rien là ça va même faire tour
f1 l'expansion mais il faut faire gaffe
que la dame bam décision menace la tour
couvre f2 et il va lui sortir g8 il a vu
l'autre il va blindés ok il a gagné
autant et c'était la dernière balle est
plus aux robots assez fantastique un
gros match de la part de maxime et donc
qui gagne 21 à 10 boucherie voilà une
belle boucherie
donc il a perdu le 5 + 1 et finalement
il a fait la différence en trois plus
sain et en ayant un plus un ennui
maintenant en lui infligeant sa 16 et
demi à quatre et demi plus de 12 sur sur
les deux derniers sur les deux derniers
deux dernières sections
je veux voir en fait si on va pas avoir
un tableau assez bien et c'est bien
visite qui commente la place dans le
7ème bien écrit eric en scène donc j'ai
pas rêver et je veux juste laissé sa psy
pour voir si on me met un petit tableau
ce qui pourrait être sympa un tableau de
co2 de la compétition
mais ne nous met pas le tableau écoute
moi je vais laisser cet écran là je vais
mettre une petite pub
ok je vais lancer une pub
après je vais un petit peu suivre pour
ceux qui veulent sur ma chaîne gary donc
si tu veux suivre entre opérateurs
qu'est ce ça marche elle serait faire et
puis je sais pas tu voir le mot de la
fin
du coup avant la hongrie sera tourné de
façon la plus pendant six minutes mais
j'ai passé où le mot de la fin au
maximum la question que je te dise de
plus bravo et merci de nous avoir suivis
je vais aller faire du piano format
merci merci à toi maxime aussi donc
merci aux deux maxime qui nous ont
offert une belle soirée et ben j'espère
qu'on se reverra qu'on se reverra
bientôt ça marche
allez merci donc les mecs on a laissé on
a laissé maxime donc on va se faire a
peut-être un petit peu de gary je laisse
jeu-là ce stream tourné pendant six sept
minutes histoire de laisser tourner la
pub et puis après on se lance on se
lance un petit stream sur bitstream et
on suit on suit gary catt vous en pensez
est ce que ça vous dit bros de façon peu
regardé la première partie et puis on
voit après je verrai un peu ca du monde
on suit la première et puis à et puis on
voit on voit ce que ça donne allez je
vous laisse les mecs on se retrouve dans
cinq minutes je lance rare est donc
resté rester ici et on se retrouve très
bientôt a tout de suite l'élite